[Laughter]
hey everybody it's friday night we're
here and this is the friday come get
drunk with us before the weekend show
because we're probably not going out
tonight or tomorrow
as broke as we are yeah
i know all those damn bills i know well
adulting blows it really does but yeah
well that's what i was just saying it's
like it's kind of you know obviously i
didn't really want to go out tonight
because i'm kind of tired but um
tomorrow night mannequins was doing
their halfway to halloween
cosplay ball
but i don't have a costume or anything
but i don't know it's just i don't i
feel like i'm just kind of broken
there was a huge
a huge um
a grocery bill last month i bought two
months worth of groceries so but i mean
at least it's two months worth yeah so
hopefully right well we have to go do
you know get vegetables yeah but that's
not i mean that was like you know yeah
that was like a [ __ ] ton of money but
right that was like [ __ ] that's gonna
last a really long time didn't even
touch the freezer
we haven't touched the freezer yet
didn't even touch it
anything i put in the freezer hasn't
even touched it well that's good yeah so
we did good on food
for a whole month
we just use the internal freezer
and i'm trying i'm trying to like not to
eat as much you know
trying to eat a little bit less okay dj
maniac says new season to joe bob starts
on shutter tonight yeah that's right and
actually last night um if you guys have
been watching cursed films
uh they put the new one up last night
which was serpents in the rainbow so
that was actually really interesting
i've been watching that they've been
putting a new one up like every thursday
um i didn't see what else they put up
because sometimes they put new movies up
to
parzival says cheers from germany i'm so
drunk tonight i'll shave my head clean
okay
[Laughter]
live in stream if a woman smokes with me
live history okay
well you gotta smoke weed
look at the um
saw a good movie last night
[ __ ] it's free on youtube right now
christopher walken
the dogs of war
they're playing it for free on youtube
it's a good it's a good retro mercenary
flick i saw it when i was a kid but i
only remembered a couple of scenes from
it
and went back and watched it and uh it
was good man it was pretty good kind of
kind of realistic it was based on a book
that was very realistic
about private contractors
helping to oust and overthrow
african governments for other guys in
africa and this big business guy big
business uh guys who are also behind it
too
and uh christopher walken plays this
mercenary in there what was his name do
you remember the name of his character
shannon yeah something shannon shannon
that was his last name i don't think
that was his first name but that's what
everybody called him and um
he uh
he's not a convincing
mercenary all right he looks cool though
he
and he delivers he looks pretty foxy in
that movie yeah he looks like david
bowie actually he does he does rather um
but uh he's not very convincing he's
real [ __ ] loud and boisterous [ __ ]
you know you know over-the-top acting
you know and in in
in on certain scenes where he's
negotiating price like come on man lower
your voice it's negotiations you know
this is businessman so how much are
these illegal weapons
[Laughter]
even though technically
technically most of the [ __ ] they were
doing was not illegal well no but yeah
it's just they try to make it [ __ ]
sound
a lot more illegal you know it's a lot
more fun a lot more fun
right
yeah [ __ ] no
now military contractors can get any
weapons they want they don't have to go
to any kind of and actually they never
they they didn't buy those illegally
they bought them legally you can get
licenses if you if you own a security
company to get anything you you need
including destructive device you know in
other words [ __ ] things that blow up
you can get that
just you just have to have your your
company has to have the right
connections
and it has to be kind of reckon
governments have to deal with it you
know
um
which i guess an african government was
dealing with it was dealing with them
but um it's a good movie pretty good
uh movie of its time
uh
practical effects
looking everything done in camera
uh they they exploded all kind of
floated all kinds of [ __ ]
kind of like a more s
more kind of believable version of like
the expendables or also al bundy was in
it yeah a lot of people like in one
scene it was like you know what i mean
what's that actor's name i can't
remember
i don't know uh
[ __ ] i'll think of it one of the bad
guys uh
from uh beverly hills cop was in it oh
and bellock was in it too
because i was like every single person
oh and joe beth williams from
poltergeist was yeah too yeah she was
only in like one or two scenes but i was
like hey that's mom for poltergeist dude
to play bellock played a french commando
that was on the team
he got killed didn't no he made it he
made it the other guy
every time i see that dude all i ever
want to say is like now you see there's
nothing possessed which i cannot take
away
which is like the best [ __ ] line
jason malloy says hi jenny and tom i
just heard about a case today that i bet
you would like look up the 1961
disappearance murder of joan risch yeah
i remember hearing about that i don't
remember like all the details of it did
i write about that
in one of my books i can't remember
because i that name is like really
really familiar but yeah i've heard that
before we might have talked about it on
one of the shows but yeah i'll have to
look it up um
and gua
guamo khan says y'all see the north man
yet no but i actually really want to i
was maybe i'll go tomorrow and see it
i don't know we'll see because i
actually do really want to see it
dj mainac says there's a free loving
rockets tones on tail tribute album on
bandcamp today
oh that sounds cool i'll dm you a link
later all current gotham dark wave
artists yeah i'd be really like uh
interested to hear that actually i like
those tribute albums i had that old uh
bauhaus tribute album that had like the
shroud [ __ ] on it that was actually
quite good
and let's see yeah define smokes you
should replace spock with a live person
dressed and posed the same and see when
someone notices yeah they're just like
having to stand there like that the
whole time then all of a sudden he goes
or he does like he does that and then
everybody's like everybody would like
[ __ ] their pants ed o'neill thank you
that's that guy's name yeah because he
goes to the guy was like uh he worked at
like a mechanic or something and he was
just like one of the guys that he went
to
like when he was trying to get the team
together try to put the ring and i was
like oh my god al bundy is a mercenary
yeah i thought he just sold shoes
that was like super funny it was kind of
cool because you know half half of the
movie is then planning the mission and
trying to get everything together
and um they don't trust the client the
client has private investigators
watching them
and
one of the private investigators
killed
a uh
a [ __ ] journalist who
christopher walken had befriended in
africa
killed him because they were afraid that
he was going to [ __ ] spill the beans
on the mission and then they didn't then
it turns out that
they're going to [ __ ] topple this
government and put the [ __ ]
generals or the president's brother in
there and the brother is the same kind
of dick as the the first one as the
original one so it was just two dicks
replacing one date with another dick
and walk him
yeah yeah and walking was kind of the
way of the world when he was in prison
he imprisoned his ass
when he was doing the recon
when he was in prison they were beating
the brother was beating the [ __ ] out of
him he's kind of like ahead of the
secret police
and while he was in there he met a
doctor and it turned out one of the
doctors was
had been imprisoned because he tried to
run for president
and they were like no you're a nice
person we can't have that right i had
him locked up in there it's pretty good
at the end you know i don't want to
spoil it that man it doesn't really
matter i mean it's old it came out in
1980 yeah
they achieved the mission and [ __ ]
walking goes in there to go
kill the [ __ ] old president it turns
out the old the
the guys that they were hired to kill
he was just a coward
the reason why he was doing all this
crazy [ __ ] is because he was afraid
people were going to kill him well they
were
but yeah he wasn't wrong he wasn't wrong
but he just but he was killing people
and [ __ ]
uh doing all this crazy [ __ ] because he
knew that they were gonna kill him
so he shot him
and then uh
[ __ ]
the new president showed up late on the
[ __ ] helicopter to take over when he
finally did show up
[ __ ] walking had to [ __ ] he he
sprung the the doctor out of prison the
good guy had him sitting up in the
presidential throne
and the guy walking says no i'm the
president and [ __ ] the doctor says no
i'm the president
and
and and [ __ ] walking shot the [ __ ]
he's like the client he shot the client
no you're not different and then the
guys the businessman for the european
business guys that were involved at the
balcony because they were platinum on
platinum in the area they wanted a
contract for it they were the ones that
were fronting all the money says man we
had negotiated with this guy you know we
we had him all paid off he goes well
you're gonna have to pay off him now
and it was it was just kind of like yeah
it's a walking dog just like deal with
it you had to deal with it
[Laughter]
what the deal was you know i guess he
figured
you know if you're just gonna replace
one dick with another if you're gonna go
through all that [ __ ] just get rid of
that dick and put a cool guy
that way at least he felt like he did
something right for all the [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] that they did to [ __ ] do
the mission and he's all beat up his
doctor's telling man you've taken 20
years off the back end of your life
because he had all those damn head
injuries and [ __ ] spineless yeah but
it's the last 20 you'll never know yeah
it's just beating him up
that i recommend i recommend it dog's a
war it's uh
fairly realistic in a way the delivery's
over the top
but it's christopher walker it's
christopher walken it is fun he's he
makes a cool commando even though he's
not really you know uh
believable but
he's cool you know and uh
try to think what else about that that
stunt where they ran over that
journalist guy was like uh startlingly
realistic yeah i was like is that guy
okay they showed this holy [ __ ] they
showed this experimental weapon it kind
of
it's almost like a proto action movie
where not only does the action star star
in it but his gun stars in it
and you know they got a picture [ __ ]
walking with this big ass [ __ ]
automatic revolver looks like [ __ ] 12
gauge or something
and it's a it's an
it was a real firearm it's xm18
it was really more of the [ __ ] kind
of a law enforcement
gas grenade launcher really what it did
but it could do other stuff too it had
little grenades and it could shoot
and uh they borrowed it
from the company that made it like
it didn't it didn't succeed it wasn't it
wasn't well i like that they actually
showed in the movie what a pain in the
ass it was to like reload
[Laughter]
well he would unload it and then hand it
to the dude behind him
yeah he had that african guy back there
he'd just give it give it to him and i
guess he was loading it and then he was
shooting
yeah you know
yeah
yeah that was a pretty good movie i just
i kind of feel like when we started
watching it i was like this seems kind
of familiar so i might have seen it like
i said i used to see [ __ ] on cable all
the time
um you know and then i just kind of
forgot about it because i just saw so
much crap the client the new president
who's paying him to overthrow the old
president says i'm gonna give you what
was it 30 of my best troops because
they're [ __ ] great you'll love him
like nah we don't we don't want any
african troops we don't deal with them
and they're like that
but then they they show up later they
they do turn up they do use them and it
turns out they were good
but the [ __ ] president was like oh no
no they're they're uh they're they will
die for their because they're patriotic
they'll die for the country
to overthrow that president and and
you
you're like [ __ ] they're showing the
mercenaries that's kind of like looking
down their noses at [ __ ] african
troops they're like no those dudes
aren't any good
but uh and you expect them not to be any
good but then when you when they show
them they're good so i kind of liked
that part of the movie they were kind of
commandos
yeah it's like just because they're not
like they don't all have uniforms and
[ __ ] like that yeah they just had
whatever clothes was laying around yeah
they said they think they can't fight
yeah
and it was another thing that was kind
of cool about it is that they were doing
everything at sea
staging it out in international waters
where there wouldn't be any political or
legal troubles you know
and uh they're linking up
with the african troops and then getting
all their [ __ ] weapons deliveries at
sea out in international waters and they
start training out there
you know [ __ ] and they train the
troops on how to use the they ordered a
[ __ ] um
about a hundred oozies and they're out
there [ __ ] training them how to use
oozies
then they give them all od green
uniforms and equipment and stuff they
equip
murder hornet is having a a
colon thing in a few days oh yeah i
can't help him
i dare you to like when you get it done
to turn around and go how dare
you and then you'll laugh and laugh and
they won't have any idea what you're
laughing yeah
guava gun says when stunts are done
right they're terrified yeah that dude
getting run out of like is that dude all
right it looked like he actually did get
run over by the car he might have i
don't know uh like that one where the
model lands on the car i can't remember
the name of the movie but i remember you
all did a review on it yeah that's right
what the [ __ ] was that movie that and it
wasn't that long ago it was probably all
landed on the car yeah yeah yeah
remember like that woman landing on the
top of the car like falling out the
building and they actually did that for
real
um but
[ __ ] the thing that happened one of
those happened in the lethal weapon
where the porn star girl [ __ ] jumped
out the window got high and jumped out
the window landed on the car maybe
that's what it was it was a movie we
just like reviewed not too long ago that
that maybe it was that but i just
remember us bringing it up on the show
because i was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
that really looked like somebody got
super hurt
you know what i mean i think there are
there were some stuntmen that actually
did do that land on the roof of a car
on their back
and uh they lived
they had it all worked out that you
could survive it
i don't know if all of the windows were
in place though because it has to
crumple correctly yeah and it probably
didn't have any
front seats
in the car yeah you think you wouldn't
want anything in there that if it
crumpled too much though it's gonna like
[ __ ] up your [ __ ] you out spine you know
that's the thing it's i guess they know
what they're doing with that [ __ ] it is
dangerous though
man they had some new york window
cleaners fall off one of those scaffolds
fall
and fell down you know like [ __ ] 50
60 stories
and it killed one dude and the other
dude lived and he was on that he rode
that scaffold down the whole way no
thank you imagine that
because it didn't
i guess because it fell like that it was
it was uh
slightly acting a little bit as a like a
parachute and then it hit cars and it
hit stuff on the way down which helps
slow it down i think it was hitting uh
awnings and stuff
god damn yeah i can't imagine and yeah
he was strapped to it you know they have
those safety harnesses well yeah they
don't just let you run around losing
yeah he couldn't fall off of it so he
had you know he stayed he rode it all
the way down
that's like my worst nightmare i'm like
so so scared of fights but that's um
it's weird because just last night just
apropos of nothing
i was thinking about
meeting uh she's getting all [ __ ]
all educated on me apropos what is
acropol apropos never even heard of it
you've never heard that word before no
meaning like pertaining to okay like
apropos of nothing usually means
you know i just thought of it out of the
clear blue there was nothing that
reminded me of it that's what i mean all
right so i thought most people knew what
that i never heard yeah okay well she
writes books that's not my fault yeah
so anyway
uh so yeah so for whatever reason last
night i was thinking of that scene
in exorcist two
where linda blair was standing right at
the edge of that building and i remember
when we watched like you know the roof
of the building in new york city
and i remember when we watched that
could be i was like wow that looks
disturbingly real i wonder how they did
that is it green screen or something
like that nope they actually made her do
that
and i'm just kind of like had that been
me if i was in that movie absolutely not
i quit
nope um
guam ko khan said that that movie was
called looker that's right yeah that's
right yeah i knew it was one of those
yeah that's right looker look i had to
look at my youtube history hello they
were using genetically no they were
doing [ __ ] uh the models had all been
analyzed by computer algorithms yeah
yeah maximum beautiful yes sell all that
[ __ ]
little did they know
god i was listening to something today
just like that reminded me of uh since
we're talking about horrible injuries
i was listening to something today every
now and then like when i'm working i'll
listen to like those you know four hours
of scary stories or whatever
like true stories and one of them was
the stories that i heard today was a
true story and it was based on like a
9-1-1 call and they had like the you
know they had it all recorded and
everything and it was a guy it happened
in florida actually and uh and i think
it was in around the orlando area
and it was a guy who was working the
night shift he was really young i think
he was only 21 or something
and he was working the night shift like
at some you know machine plant factory
or something like that and his leg got
caught in a machine what was it a baler
and it cut his leg off like a you know
below the knee
and there was really nobody there but
him or there was nobody in that one area
and so there's this really really long
like sustained
9-1-1 call and like the 9-1-1 people
like they couldn't find where the
factory was and he was just kind of like
going in and out like he was bleeding to
death and it was just like oh my god it
was the most [ __ ] harrowing thing i
ever heard they said when he first
called he was like super calm and he was
like um yeah my my leg just got cut off
like in a baler machine and i need an
ambulance and he said where it was and
he was like had all his [ __ ] together
but obviously like the more blood that
he was losing he did live um so because
the whole time i've listened to like
please don't tell me this poor dude this
poor dude died after all of this but he
did live all right i'm gonna tell a
story you guys are gonna trip out on
this hornet's nest he's gonna he's gonna
like this one
when i was in the 327th down at uh
fort campbell when i was in 101st we
went on this field problem
we do a training mission we're out in
the back 40.
and uh this particular night
i was uh
near the company cp in a little position
there we were sleeping and we got a
[ __ ] hit by op4 just you know our own
guys
you know just
colored bands around their helmets you
know i mean they represent the enemy so
we got in this [ __ ] firefight with
blanks and [ __ ]
and it was nighttime
after it was all over
um
i just saw a commotion and [ __ ] heard
commotion from a distance
and could see con you know i didn't it
was night time but you could see them it
was there was enough light from the moon
like i see a a gaggle of people
[ __ ] up by one of the humvees
and [ __ ] um
oh i know this story yeah i'll buy one
of the humvees
and there's a commotion and [ __ ] and i'm
going what the [ __ ] are they doing
and then the [ __ ] about a minute
later
they [ __ ]
that whole crowd went and went towards
the back
and [ __ ] somebody runs up and says
[ __ ]
they're they're medevac and [ __ ]
sergeant gillard is a bad [ __ ] he's
been badly injured and he was like what
the [ __ ] happened and it says some rebar
went up his ass
yeah i was like what
yeah and [ __ ] this is what happened
man
and finally they i'm cringing just
thinking about it you told me this story
this is what i have
sergeant galarza was in the [ __ ]
humvee
and the um
he was in there sleeping
and uh when when when we got hit by the
by off four
and he got up
and ran
got went over the [ __ ]
went over the [ __ ] windshield or had
the windshield down i don't remember how
it was i think the windshield went down
on that or you could step over and he
was on the hood
of the humvee shooting at him and
[ __ ] yelling at some other guys
and he went to go run off the front of
the
[ __ ] know the humvee hood is almost
perfectly square and on the ends of it
there's a couple of [ __ ] rebar that
go up with a [ __ ] tennis ball on top
of them and they're they were welded to
the bumpers
to help
to help you guide the card for [ __ ]
loading you know uh so you know what
your clearances are if you can get in
and out of something or pull it in the
back of the aircraft or whatever
well
there's supposed to be a tennis ball on
the end of it
and uh his car that vehicle didn't have
the tennis balls and he went to go run
off the hood and jump off the [ __ ]
corner and that rebar went
right up
right next to his [ __ ]
and went up into his body as he fell and
when his by the time his feet hit the
ground he was standing there and that
rebar was up inside of his abdomen and
went all the way up into his lungs
and he couldn't get off of it
uh yeah he's sitting there like that
he's calling for help i had to lift him
off of it oh my god
he said he could feel it going this way
well yeah i said he was gone for weeks
and when he came back he was like a hero
[ __ ]
sergeant golovkin i'm again man i'm not
a virgin no more
well yeah of course they had
they had to put
a [ __ ] hose all the way up that hole
and flush it out
and clean it out before they could [ __ ]
and then they just put some stitches
that's all they couldn't really do
anything it went up into his lungs and
everything
but it healed
imagine that
oh i am i am imagining it that's why i'm
horrified it makes me never ever want to
like get out of my chair ever again and
like walk anywhere or do it he had been
impaled yikes by a piece of [ __ ]
rebar i mean and the fact that he was
still like able to come back and he was
all right yeah i went back like nothing
happened holy [ __ ] yeah what a badass
yeah
sergeant galarza
uh guama khan also says i saw a video
how some dude fell onto some cylinder
type barricade thing ass first and it
bulged out of his shoulder yeah didn't
even break the skin it was gnarly yeah
[ __ ] hell murder hornet says jenny
forgot the price uh on again on your
gift oh thank you but it was a five
finger discount so don't matter
john smith says worst onset injury
twilight zen movie oh yeah big time uh
if you guys don't know we reviewed the
twilight zone movie but in the um the
first segment
about the the guy that goes back in time
like to nazi germany or whatever uh
yeah vic morrow and two
little vietnamese kids
who weren't really supposed to be
working
um got beheaded by a helicopter crash
so that's nice yeah
i can tell you about sergeant smith
that's [ __ ] horrible sergeant smith
was a friend of mine he liked uh [ __ ]
cure and everything we went to egypt
together
and
when he was a private
he was in that operation um
operation just cause
i think it was just cause that was the
um just because just cuz
really that's kind of what it was well
yeah that's why i was making that [ __ ]
when they invaded panama and ousted
noriega
all right
for drug dealing that probably we were
involved in that's some [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] anyway
they [ __ ] flew his ass in there and
uh along with his unit and i think he
was it was he was still in the 101st at
that time i believe but then he went
back he left and then went back it was
24th tropical lightning i don't remember
which unit it was he was with when he
did it but he was in the hundred first
one on them
and uh part of thing was they had to
attack this pdf compound which is a
[ __ ] panamanian police
panamanian defense force compound
and you know they were all [ __ ] they
didn't even know they were at war or
anything you know and it was just kind
of [ __ ] standard operation where
we're gonna get down here we're gonna
walk with [ __ ] choppers to drop you
off here you're gonna walk down the road
on either side [ __ ] you're going to
set up position here and you're going to
blow up the [ __ ] guard post you're
going to shoot anybody that comes out of
there and then [ __ ] later on you're
just going to shoot the whole place up
and uh then where some helicopter's
going to come and blow some [ __ ] up and
then you're going to walk in there and
[ __ ] see if they surrender that kind
of crap
so
they get to the front gate and they're
[ __ ] on the side of the road
and uh they're kind of up in the bushes
and it's like three o'clock in the
morning and then they [ __ ] get down
in a [ __ ]
get down on [ __ ] on the ground
laying down and they're just looking at
the damn guard post and it's just a
little [ __ ] fiberglass
guard shack with sandbags around it and
the guy's running a uh one of those
little [ __ ] gates it's just nothing
but a pole you know there's a stop sign
on it
it goes up and down and then there's a
chain link fence going around the whole
army compound it's just barracks and
[ __ ]
and um
so he's running that
and they had like a [ __ ]
pre-planned time when everything was
when and people were gonna attack it's
all gonna attack at the same time
you know across all of panama panama
didn't even know that we had waged war
on them or anything get out of it i
think i think the [ __ ] the
declaration happened at the same time
that the attack was supposed to happen
and uh
all the units all the american units in
panama the ones that were stationed
there have had sandbags all over the
[ __ ] place they'd been doing
[ __ ] um
training missions everywhere
uh for weeks so the panamanian
government had no idea that that was
going to turn into an attack
but that's how it went down sneak attack
well sergeant smith
as a private they gave him an at4 rocket
it's a disposable [ __ ] fiberglass
rocket in a tube
and uh
what his [ __ ] sergeant told him to do
just [ __ ] put it right there on the
door and [ __ ] when he [ __ ] hits
him on the shoulder go ahead and launch
it and that was going to happen at the
[ __ ] at go time so
go time came [ __ ] sergeant hit him on
the shoulder which is his signal to
[ __ ] shoot it he'd already had it
lined up and the second the dude hit him
the [ __ ] the guard and the shacks
moved into the doorway and [ __ ] he
fired the missile and that missile went
down there and it's a missile by the big
round as a coffee can and about 18
inches long
and it [ __ ] lobbed out boom and it
hit and it hit that dude right in the
[ __ ] stomach
and blew the
[ __ ]
blew the [ __ ] fiberglass [ __ ]
thing to shreds
and then all and then they all started
shooting and firing and guys all kinds
of stuff happened one of the things that
was funny when they were shooting at the
compound a guy on a [ __ ] motorcycle
[ __ ]
exited the [ __ ] base going full
[ __ ] speed probably about 70. and he
goes through a hail of [ __ ] tracer
fire
and just a random 40 millimeter grenade
out of a m203 hit on the back of that
motorcycle
on the back seat and blew him up into
the air and he [ __ ] went into the
ditch on the other side
after the whole [ __ ] attack was over
they went down and found that dude he
was alive with his hands up like that
and they were like dude he started
laughing because you know we got we got
spanish speakers in the unit they're
like dude you're alive he's yeah i made
it not a scratch on him not a scratch on
him
they picked him up gave him cigarettes
and [ __ ] feeding because the attack
was over
you know uh [ __ ] anyway what i was
gonna say is
the dude that got hit in the [ __ ]
stomach
lived
well he was a lot of [ __ ] he was alive
when they found him
he died later
but
his bottom at his bottom
and [ __ ] starting smith took a photo
of him
but it was after he died took a photo of
him
looks like he's coming out of the ground
it's just a waste in a guy's arms like
that and that's how he was standing he
was standing like that
holding himself up he was gasping for
air when they found it
there was they were like dude we're
gonna get you some help
we're gonna get you some help man but he
died
i mean yeah i i would think that it's
kind of blew him in two jesus christ and
he was alive for about 15 minutes
ugh
yeah man if some [ __ ] like that's gonna
happen to me i'd rather just die
immediately because holy [ __ ] it's like
knowing that you're like that
that's gonna be [ __ ] horrible yeah
and [ __ ] he showed me the picture and
showed the picture and he's up on his
stump like that there's blood everywhere
in the pool around him with his hands
down supporting himself and he was dead
though at the time but he was that's the
way he died because he didn't tip over
you know i guess the way the weight was
and the shape you know but it looked
like a damn
straight cut like you put them through a
meat slicer
i don't know how it happened
just had something to do with being hit
in the gut with a shaped charge
i mean because he lived we're just meat
bags yeah i know that's scary to think
about but
[ __ ] scary
yeah honestly one of the most [ __ ] up
things i ever saw that i don't know why
this i've seen grosser [ __ ] like on the
internet like real pictures and stuff
but for some reason this picture really
disturbed me
and it was a photograph it was a guy
who had been he just like robbed a store
or some [ __ ] like that i don't know so
he was like running away from the cops
and he was running across like some
building roofs i don't remember what
city this was but he was running across
like some building roofs and i guess he
either jumped or fell like he was trying
to like jump to another building and he
didn't make it
and he fell and landed exactly right on
one of those like fences or gates that
are kind of like the the iron thing with
like kind of the spikes at the top
and it actually like got his head it got
his head like right under here and just
pulled his whole body was off so his
head was still there on the spike and
then his body was down here and it was
like and it was the freakiest thing i
ever saw because his head it didn't look
like super gory or anything like that it
looked fake but it was real like he just
had like a very peaceful like expression
on his face
and
there's just like a head right there
like on the thing and then there's like
the rest of his body underneath he just
caught it exactly right
that it just like he landed right like
that and just pulled his [ __ ] head
off like the weight and i was just kind
of like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] that was like
the most i don't know why that creeped
me out so much it wasn't even gory or
anything but it's just the way that it
looked like really spooked me out
um
lionex where you're getting drunk oh no
can't be doing that
well rebecca said it was 8 a.m she
couldn't get drunk well you can but it's
probably not the best idea
yeah i mean
i don't know it's grand they're saying
there's all kinds of pictures
pictures of russians dying in a bunch of
different ways you can't really trust
any picture you see because you don't
have the context you don't know what war
it was or where
and a lot of times you can't tell what
country it is
grampter's also said trivia who is vic
mora's daughter answer jennifer jason
lee i don't think i actually knew that
and then john smith said wow i'm
guessing she's never worked with john
landis yeah probably not
because you know i mean john landis he
had to go well it wasn't just him but it
was like some of the other people on the
crew too like twilight's in the movie
and they actually had to go
to court for
what were this what was the charge i
think it was i don't think it was
manslaughter it might have been
negligent homicide or something like
that because
um they just there there were some
rules that were worked around and like i
said the two little kids that were there
it was like the middle of the night and
they weren't really supposed to be
working like they were it was kind of
under the table and it was all that kind
of stuff and i don't know but they
determined that there were wasn't any
fault but i still kind of feel like
people
still blame them a little bit and pr
like understandably so i would imagine
because
you know
uh
dean
yeah rebecca said uh my fiance at the
time was deployed to tim moore tim moore
to moore yeah
during the conflict with indonesia and
he showed me pics of women naked with
broomsticks shoved in the vagina through
the mouth horrifying yeah
yeah well that kind of [ __ ] goes all the
way back to [ __ ] um
the 30s
um
japan was doing that to the chinese
japanese imperial army
there was something called the the rape
of nanjing or nate ray banan king and
some of those photos were [ __ ]
surfaced
um
when uh during that island fighting
usgis
would go you know go through the [ __ ]
bodies of the enemy dead they'd find
those photographs they couldn't didn't
have the context just them
them [ __ ] raping
gang raping girls and killing them and
stuff in photos and they were like where
is the hell is this it was because those
guys have been
serving in nanjing and china before they
got sent out there to those islands
i read a really good um
fictional book
uh called the devil of nanking and it
was kind of like partially based on i
mean it's kind of set in the modern day
but it was partially based on
it had a lot of uh the history of that
like in there and uh somebody that was
looking for a lost film or lost
photographs from back then it was
actually like really really good and
really disturbing because i feel like
that's something that they don't really
teach all that much over here the whole
rape of nanking oh yeah uh people here
man [ __ ] going off about how racist
america is you don't know the far east
man you've never lived there
well it's not a competition yeah oh man
that's there man the koreans the
japanese and the chinese and the
vietnamese and and the lawasians and
everything the cambodians all hate each
other thousands of years of fighting
they they can't stand each other now
sometimes there's some crossover but
oh man bad
john smith says the night king massacre
was an atrocity so bad it was officially
condemned by the nazis yeah you really
have to question your life choices when
even the nazis are going bro yeah yeah
that's that's pretty well there were
stuff happening in eastern europe um by
uh
government governments that were allied
with the axis powers and uh you had guys
from the concentration camps
[ __ ] um from the concentration camps
uh system going into eastern europe
going on oh no these dudes here [ __ ]
we can't stand with this they were doing
all kinds of boiling people alive and
turning them into soap and that's what
they were doing that uh i can't remember
the name
i think estacia or usda i forgot what
they were called they weren't really
nazis but they were kind of
kind of like them
trying to remember what sometimes i
wonder though like somebody like say you
know say you're a nazi and then you go
and see something that's like worse than
what you're doing yeah sometimes i
wonder if that's like well shoo i
thought i was a bad person but clearly
this is a bad person what i'm doing is
okay like i wonder if it's like some
kind of like weird justification
it's always it's always okay
you know what i mean
it's okay do you know what i mean
they're doing it to enemies because they
hate those enemies well i hate them
because they feel that they're bad
and they're bad so therefore we had to
get rid of them we can't live with them
it's all you could always justify it
they always justify it in the mod yeah i
know it's because they've just been
hated well if they couldn't then they
wouldn't do it do it right then they
wouldn't do it right so they always see
it as i'm saving my country well that's
saving my people that's always why they
do dehumanization against the enemy like
you call them racist names or you say
they're not the same as you somehow like
they're not human they're subhuman it's
always something like that so it's
easier to yeah but that happens
naturally it happens in the population
first
and then the governments also believe
that so then they start saying that
you know
yeah
it's not like it's made up out of whole
cloth well i didn't i didn't imply that
yeah you can't do it that way
what happens is that the government is
made up of the same people that are
voting well yeah and the same people who
are putting all these people in
so um
so there's a uniformity of opinion
uh but then you have like a a synergy
builds up
to where it's just basically kind of
like
mass
it's a mass psychology mass uh uh
uh mass psychology mass formation starts
happening
to where um
i guess you say it's kind of like
mass insanity but it's also kind of like
mass
mass homicide
you know they
they're just gonna they're they're
they're sick of the [ __ ]
and it's gonna be either you know where
somebody's gotta go so it's it's uh
and it's not something unusual it's been
happening all of human
history
well yeah that's just yeah i think
everybody's pretty familiar with that i
mean i mean scapegoating is a really
easy thing to do like
especially if there's some problems and
it's like well these problems are too
complex to solve but obviously it's all
their fault it's all you know it's these
group of people if we just get rid of
them then everything will be fine and uh
uh shockingly amount of people will
actually go along with that yeah uh
guama khan says my high school textbook
had photos of the rape from night king i
can't remember because i mean high
school for me was like a long time ago
i think it was mentioned in my world
history class but i don't know if we did
because to be honest i had a world
history class in high school
um and i had one in uh junior higher
middle school as well but i don't know
it was mostly europe-centric i don't
know if they focus they did do a little
bit like on asia and africa and stuff
like that but i don't think that was
like the main it was just kind of like
an afterthought it was like i said it
was mostly like european history to be
honest so that's kind of what they
covered but they i think they did
mention it but i don't think they went
like super super into it but i'd be
curious as to like what the technology
maniac you're asking a question without
context maybe it gives them ideas i
don't know what you're talking about
we're talking about because i was
talking about uh the nazis going and
seeing something worse than the nazis
and then it was like oh hey we never
even thought of that i'm going to write
that down
no um according to the guy who [ __ ]
saw the ussr doing that [ __ ] he said he
said he was horrified because it wasn't
happening within the confines of a camp
they were just doing it out in the open
they weren't necessarily killing people
they were just horribly maiming people
and letting them go to die
one guy said that he was walk as he went
there he saw
a 14 year old girl nude
walking towards him that had a spike
driven through her pelvic region
and they i think it cut her lips off
and and her arms i think and they just
let her go
and then he went there and he feels that
they were making soap out of people and
boiling people alive and it wasn't a big
uh
it wasn't like a death factory like uh
like the
the germans would have done it was just
like a traveling circus that was set up
and let's wipe out about 100 people from
this area
uh their enemies
and it was kind of like in a
carnival-like
environment
you know that's the kind of hatred that
had built up well the thing about it too
is that maybe germans or the nazis could
kind of justify because it's like well
we're doing it like systematic
systematic like the right way yeah it's
a systematic euthanasia of an enemy
that has no future because they had all
different ways of
but it's not just them
people have done this for [ __ ] all of
human history
uh uh genocides it starts off just it's
tribal one tribe wiping out another
tribe
and um
it's because they were in conflict
before you see the the whole
anti-semitic thing just didn't come out
of nowhere that had been going on for
two thousand years all the way back to
rome
you know um
because
i guess you could say the prob [ __ ]
ethnic
[ __ ]
ethnic
problems uh ethnic hatred between
uh i guess you could say caucasians and
caucasians and and and jews goes back
all the way back to the rome's war
against judea
and the destruction of their temple it
goes back that far
and then well yeah that's a very long
stance right and then after that
when rome fell it became basically a
bunch of christian kingdoms
well this is christian territory so you
you have to be a christian in order to
own land
everybody no one else could own any land
so jews couldn't own land uh peasants
couldn't own land either but even when
all that [ __ ] started
to shake shake out
still was jews not could not only own
land they couldn't be in political
parties
so they formed their own political
parties one of them the communist
parties was later on you know
so it went on for 2 000 years
you know it's not it wasn't just hey
this mustache man [ __ ] showed up and
did this man
well no i don't think anybody thinks
that i mean everybody is pretty
i thought everybody was pretty familiar
with the facts no no no that it's been
going on for like it was going on way
before that because it's you know it was
a pretty deep-seated thing in europe
that he actually exploited for that
exact reason i mean they they were
excited i think he believed it well he
did but i'm just saying you know it it
ended up like you know the the result of
it was yeah you know that yeah but no
there's a lot of people that don't know
it all you gotta do is just look in the
comment sections especially people under
the age of 40 a lot of them don't know
much about it
they just think some dude showed up and
did that made people do that
no one man can't make people do that it
was
just it was the way it was just the way
that society was you know and it's
something that had built up it was just
a long race war
granter's hammer has several uh topic
these are all good actually so let me
read them all and then we'll we'll get
to them in order
best meal to cook a woman if you want to
have boom boom time later okay okay yeah
obvious signs you're dating a sociopath
ooh that should be a fight
well no because then by the time you
finish talking about that then it'll be
way the [ __ ] back up there and i'll have
to like go find it again obvious science
you're dating a sociopath
best school teachers and why and how to
beat a polygraph test
uh
best best meal to cook would be a
chicken cordon bleu women tend to like
that one with maybe some kind of like uh
that's so old-school it's old-school
[ __ ]
but hey that that that'd be that thing i
mean i guess it would depend on the
woman yeah you know okay what was the
next question
uh she's gonna
she's gonna say no but okay go ahead
well no i like chicken corn on blue okay
i'm just saying that i don't know if
there's one answer like right across the
board because it depends on what i mean
honestly if it was me um i don't know
there's a lot of different things okay
so what was the second question uh the
second question was obvious signs you
were dating a sociopath
she brings her boyfriend over to meet
you when
yeah that should be a big red flag right
there
uh what else i mean sociopathy is like
pretty well not necessarily it's not
usually easy to detect at least early on
um
because well not so much sociopaths but
psychopaths tend to be
uh like shallowly charming um so a lot
of times they can kind of
like snake their way in because they're
good at like faking
being like a charming normal person and
then sometimes you don't find out until
later
that they actually don't give a [ __ ] and
everything is like all fake
but
i don't know like early signs you're
dating a sociopath um
i'll have to think about that a little
bit more
best school teachers and why
huh best school teachers and why like
your favorite teachers i don't know you
don't know yeah
oh you tell me what the
ones that i liked yeah
[ __ ] why would you talk about that the
[ __ ] uh because it's an interesting
question
[Laughter]
i don't know i didn't really like any of
them man really i liked a lot of my
teachers now there were some that i
couldn't stand and like wanted to kill
them but
i i actually got pretty lucky like most
of my teachers were actually either
pretty cool or completely innocuous
i can think of a couple that i really
hated like with the heat of a thousand
songs most of them i can't even really
recall they didn't make much impression
but
honestly um
one of my favorite teachers ever
was my sixth grade teacher mrs hart she
was [ __ ] awesome i loved her
um she was just like a really really
awesome person i wonder if she's still
around
um i also had a couple
teachers in
was it ginger high
no i guess it was high school
i had one english my english teacher i
think from 10th grade mrs hutchinson she
was [ __ ] awesome actually me and my
friends loved her so much that like we
used to go visit her at her house like
after we graduated like a few times we
actually like went to see her because
she was so [ __ ] rad but yeah i had
like i had some really good [ __ ] uh i
had some really good teachers i had one
teacher though
in
uh middle school junior high they called
it junior high when we were kids
uh mr wagner i still remember that
dude's name i hope he's i kind of hope
he's dead by now he probably is
but man what a [ __ ] [ __ ] that
dude was what did he teach he taught um
i think he taught government or civics
or history or something like that
and um
man what a [ __ ] dick bag that dude
was god he sucked
super racist too now that i'm thinking
about it
people didn't complain about as much
about it back then because i think
everybody's just like oh okay but yeah
in in hindsight i was like jesus christ
he would have got so fired
but he didn't
uh how to beat a polygraph test
beating a polygraph to i mean basically
all you would have to do is just not
polygraph test doesn't measure whether
you're lying or not it just measures how
nervous you are or like indicators that
you're nervous like sweaty or your heart
rate or something like that so if you're
able to like keep your [ __ ] cool
even when you're
you know saying yeah i totally didn't do
that murder even though you did
then
you know that i mean there's a reason
why they're not admissible in court is
because they're not because you can beat
them
you know yeah grams that's about julia
salisbury
julia salisbury was our drama teacher
i didn't you know julia salisbury i
didn't
sh
i tolerated her you know i mean she was
a good teacher when it came when it came
to teaching drama but some of that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] goofy you know she was kind
of [ __ ] goofy
um
but no it's not like uh i wouldn't say
you didn't really like like her as a
friend or anything you know she just
she was
nice to us
but i knew she was a goofball
you know what's wrong with being a
goofball nothing it's just
if you see if you you know if you knew i
was talking if you knew or you noticed
all my she's flaky
was she like the teacher in uh heather's
that was just kind of like uh
what was she called mrs fleming i don't
remember we should know what they made
she made everybody hold hands
and [ __ ] like that yeah yeah yeah yeah
she's like one of those that's great
miss fleming you call me when the
shuttle lands that's right
yeah yeah
yeah
but you know that was her stick
i had an art teacher that was kind of
not that bad but yeah she was kind of
like that too yeah
she's one of those very like and i don't
you know i don't have anything
you know i don't have anything like
super against hippies but if they're
that hippie then yeah i'm just kind of
like let's let's not okay i'm just like
not i'm a little too like cynical for
that kind of stuff but i don't have
anything against hippies in general it's
just
you know
uh
she was a good drama teacher though yeah
yeah
she knew tell you about all the
different kind of acting method acting
and everything and
everything about blocking and
no she was good she was good
rebecca was able to raise a lot of money
yeah she could raise a lot of money for
those shows they were good
they were real good they always had
people that could sing remember christy
watson that girl could [ __ ] sing
steve kissing i was okay i got better
later but [ __ ]
christy watson could could sing her ass
off
she should have went pro but she's got
kids she's got like about a million kids
now
she's got a quiver full family oh dear
yeah she's a christian girl she's got
good christians she's got the clown car
vagina i must be
[Laughter]
she's creating a whole [ __ ] i mean
just you do you hon you just have as
many kids as you want i just i just
can't she's one of those i just can't
imagine but she was cute though yeah
that's that's really funny um art wait
who is our drama teacher
all i can remember i mean mr williams
was i was in the chorus or choir
and mr williams was the
head of that and that dude was
kind of a weirdo
uh
and i think he had something to do with
the drama thing but i don't think he was
actually the drama teacher our drama
program was actually really good like in
high school i still remember
them doing west side story and it was
amazing it was like really really good
we had like a really good what the [ __ ]
was that girl's name she was in choir
too but she was also in drama i can't
remember her name she was a big big tall
girl with like real real long blonde
hair and she had a gorgeous gorgeous
singing voice so she always got like the
lead and everything and i can't remember
what her [ __ ] name is
but um but yeah she i think she was in
that and like
i can't remember who else was in it but
i remember going to see it like a bunch
of times i was like man you guys are
incredible that it was like professional
you know what i mean yep
yeah some schools [ __ ] could kick ass
yeah trenton trenton was one that kicked
ass and it was really because julia
salisbury
she was good and
she could finagle lots of money out of
the school because they had good
turnouts
you know what i mean yeah they had good
turnouts [ __ ]
you know the only when that when a show
happened it was only two nights but it
was packed
yeah i think ours they i mean
i remember the west side story one
and i think they did
two or three like evening shows like for
the parents and all that kind of crap or
the community
and then they would do a couple shows
like during the day
so they would do like a matinee so if
you wanted to go see it they'd give you
like a break like you know so you could
go watch it because it was like an hour
or something
so i ended up going to see it like a
bunch i think i got in for free because
i was in the chorus so i got like i got
the hook up but he was great man he
could [ __ ] do [ __ ] sing roger wet
water songs and [ __ ]
like [ __ ] do pink floyd and
play uh but he was a good [ __ ] bass
player and new music theory and [ __ ] he
was [ __ ] great
and he always got the male leads if it
was if it was musical if it was a
musical should he
carry a whole damn show
yeah the girl i'm thinking of was kind
of like that too i wish i can't remember
what her goddamn name was i wasn't you
know i didn't i knew her because i was
in chorus too but i didn't like she
wasn't like in my friend group kind of
and um but man she yeah she was like a
really good singer too but and she
always got the lead and everything but i
can't remember what her name was and uh
because like i said high school was a
long time ago and i don't know why i
just remembered this
but
like i said i was in chorus and we went
to
regionals
uh in which was in what the [ __ ] city
was it and i don't remember but we had
to go somewhere like on a bus and we had
to like all stay in hotels and stuff so
everybody was like two in a room or four
in a room or whatever so we're all in
the room and mr williams who was the
choir director who like i said he was
okay but he was like a little bit of a
weirdo and man if you like pissed him
off he was he was a little tiny dude
like he was you know i mean he was
probably like a little bit taller than
me and i'm only five before and he was
like really really skinny and he kind of
had like a little beard and a mustache
and um
and if you got him angry i mean his
whole little face would like just red
red red and then he was like his veins
would pop out and he'd start throwing
[ __ ] and everything like if he got
really bad like in banging on the piano
and then he'd have to like go in the
other room to like calm down and [ __ ]
then he'd come back and pick it alright
i'm fine now but it's like so he would
like have a tantrum which we always
thought was [ __ ] hilarious so we'd
always kind of try to do it on purpose
but
when we when we went at this hotel
for what i don't even remember what the
situation was but we were all in the
room and it was kind of like 10 or 11 at
night
and we're kind of like just hanging out
there watching tv or like doing our hair
or whatever the [ __ ] and somebody said
look out in the hall like mr williams is
acting like really really weird so we
all kind of like peek out the door
and mr williams is walking down it was
one of those uh you know hotels like
[ __ ] i don't know like holiday inn or
something like that where the rooms and
there's like outside it's like the
sidewalk and so he's walking around on
the second floor and he's going like
this
like walking the other thing like that
and we're like what the [ __ ] is he doing
and we i think
he was high as [ __ ]
and it's like because his eyes looked
real [ __ ] up so i guess like he'd gone
to this hotel thing and he's just like
in his hotel room getting all [ __ ] up
and then he decided he was gonna like
walk down the [ __ ] sidewalk in front
of all the people's rooms like a freak
it was [ __ ] hilarious me and graham
had a math teacher
and graham had a math teacher uh down
there trenton high who used to get high
he had long [ __ ] brown hair and he
was dating a female student
yeah he was dating her we had that
happen in high school too they actually
got married later yeah she she was a
senior
but he wasn't he wasn't an old guy
though you know i mean yeah i mean some
of the teachers yeah some of the
teachers
were you know i mean we had teachers
that were only in their 20s so they were
only like a few years older than us
i mean it was still weird but it wasn't
that way yeah somebody saw him they were
out there
in the [ __ ] teacher's parking lot
[ __ ] smoking weed making out
then he went back
because one time he
me and mike kowalski were [ __ ]
sneaking in late
into school late or something one time
we passed that dude in the hallway when
he passed us got a whiff of that [ __ ]
weed and michael went damn and [ __ ]
teacher one way because because you
smell
and
it
goes is it he goes should i put some
cologne on it
yeah yeah
get some patchouli dude come on get over
that [ __ ] yeah yeah put some cologne on
because i look at him
i mean that's the thing about weed is
that
yeah okay well that's the thing about
weed it's like can you smell it yes yes
obviously you can smell it from what he
knew that we smoked he could tell yeah
he was uh he you know but i like the way
everybody tried to be like all sneaky
about it and i'm just kind of like look
you can smell that from like a mile away
so i don't really know who you think
you're full he didn't give a [ __ ] he
didn't give a [ __ ] he did not get
um
and he's dating [ __ ] 18 year old i'm
talking about like kids that smoke in
the house and then they their parents
are what i'm not smoking weed in here
i'm like dude yeah come on gramps
remember mr brown that's right
[Laughter]
he knew exactly who i was talking about
and he was he was [ __ ] [ __ ] down
that [ __ ] girl how old was mr brown
late 20s maybe
20s but he didn't give a [ __ ] he didn't
give him dougie brown aka druggie brown
yeah
doug brown that's right duncan everybody
loved him he was [ __ ] hilarious
but he was obviously a [ __ ] stoner
he had a mullet [ __ ] parted in the
middle and [ __ ] i mean i'm kind of
um i mean i'm up the opinion like if
you're a teacher or something like that
it's like if you're smoking weed if you
can still show up on time every day and
it's still like a capable teacher then
who gives a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
what you do like on your [ __ ] down
time
yeah it's all good he's teaching math
like i said did the kids learn math good
yeah
gold yeah and he did fine he didn't give
a [ __ ]
the thing is is that trenton was trenton
was a well disciplined school there
wasn't
there was a quiet in the class people
did their work pretty much you know i
mean it wasn't there wasn't a whole lot
of fights or anything it was just a it
was a middle class
michigan
yeah i mean our
car manufacturing town school
it was
it was like something out of back the
future just like that
very generic but good real stable you
had crazy [ __ ] going on but that that
[ __ ] has always gone on in high schools
american high schools are always kind of
crazy
but he just you could tell [ __ ] brown
was [ __ ] with smoking weed
you could tell he was high but people
were just like the students would just
smirk
yeah yeah you getting [ __ ] high
yeah he didn't care if he got fired
that's that's i think that's why he
stayed there because that was his
superpower yeah he never did he ever get
fired
i don't know [ __ ] grandpa's uh
granter said he got fired over diddling
a girl named julie yeah last name
intentionally yeah probably that same
girl we knew about
so that's
that's not ideal
what he did was his girlfriend basically
i mean think how old was he he i think
he was in his 20s
and i think the girl that they're
talking about
the girl that i'm talking about was a
senior
so she wasn't underage i think she's
about 18.
grampher said he once stapled the window
curtains clothes so we could watch a
movie in class
[Laughter]
that's awesome it's too bright in here
god damn it the whole thing the whole
thing about how you couldn't you
couldn't date students is kind of a
newer
concept from what way i understood it
is that as long as they weren't under
age
and each state had its own laws about
what underage was
and what statutory rape was
which is there's too much age difference
but really usually what that meant was
is that if they were 17 they were
usually good to go
unless you were five years older than
them that kind of [ __ ] there was it
depends on whatever state it is
yeah it's usually kind of like a thing
of because honestly it's
i don't love it because it's usually
kind of like oh teachers are usually in
a position of authority over and it's
probably like and maybe you should
probably if you do want to date them and
you're not really that much older maybe
you should just wait till they graduate
if you like them that much you should
probably just wait just you know for the
sake of propriety so nobody will think
anything um
it's kind of like it's kind of the same
thing as granny says no he was in his
40s he was that old okay well then
that's creepy no i thought he was
younger than that but well i mean it's
kind of the same thing as like [ __ ]
your boss yeah it's just kind of like
it's just not the best idea you know
what i'm saying it's like if you want to
really date that person maybe one of you
should quit so there's not kind of like
implications of favoritism and all this
other kind of [ __ ] going on
so he was in his 40s and she was yeah
okay well that's weird
i thought he was younger than that he
didn't seem to be in his 40s i thought
he was in his late 20s early 30s i mean
we i had a situation kind of like oh
jason willie asked tom and jenny would
you guys do shows about bob ross and
fred rogers we should actually because
netflix just put up a documentary about
um bob ross so kind of about his estate
and it was actually like really
fascinating bob ross is a fascinating
character and actually like probably
fred rogers was too i should actually
write that down because i probably would
like to do that because we'll just do a
show about anything
why well that's okay well they're asking
for it yeah
we usually do true romance a true
romance
[Laughter]
usually do true crime
or and paranormal and and unsolved
mystery well yeah but i mean i kind of
like any words sort of like title
interest how do you word that in the
title of the video to make that
sound like [ __ ]
an unsolved mystery
are you just gonna do it i don't know i
don't i don't think that much about it
it's like i know that but it's like
i don't know it's hard because i know
that that probably
it's better
for
the channel
to be more focused yeah but on the other
hand
i'm really interested in lots and lots
of different things and like sometimes
i'm like oh yeah that would make it like
a really good show even though it
doesn't really like fit in i don't know
i've been thinking about
maybe well i'm gonna do
i'm gonna start doing um i'm doing a new
like
blog website type thing with more like
long-form writing like book and movie
reviews and i'm gonna do a horror one
and i'm gonna do a true crime one i
might also do
youtube channels to go with those but
we'll see that'll be like later on in
the year probably because that's like
kind of a lot of work still
but
because i know that like usually
channels that tend to do better are ones
that are more focused i know ours is
kind of like all over the place just
just because like i said we're
interested in so many different things
but
i don't know grantor says that she was
still a student
so he didn't go to jail but he did get
canned yeah she was 18. but
yeah he didn't give a [ __ ] though that
dude did not give a [ __ ] he got fired i
could tell he didn't care he was a
student he i could tell that he didn't
care that he was a
a teacher he didn't really like it i
don't think
i don't think he really [ __ ] gave a
[ __ ]
i mean some people really like being
teachers i don't
and i've i had some teachers like that
that really really seemed to to really
like enjoy it
i don't think well i don't really like
kids or teenagers or people in general
really so i so i don't think i'd be very
good at it
he was obviously not taking it seriously
yeah he was doing the job
but he was also getting high and chasing
girls and not giving a [ __ ] and letting
letting students know that he was
[ __ ] good eye he didn't care he
didn't care he didn't care
[Music]
i guess he figured well all he could do
is fire me
yeah that was his that was yeah and i
guess he didn't think about it
yeah
bundy data says our history teacher got
knocked by the football captain she was
34. yeah damn
yeah we had a similar situation well it
didn't really go that far i'm not naming
any names but
uh we had a teacher who actually we all
loved he was like a cool guy he's
probably in his 40s married i think he
had a kid or two
and he
um
fell madly in love with a
friend of mine
who was 17.
yeah
and uh
they didn't do anything because she was
just kind of like bro you're like old
enough to be my dad no thank you and she
also had a boyfriend
uh who was her age
and so she was like a little weirded out
by it but it was kind of like a
situation there for a while a situation
so yeah
my drama teacher in brazil tried to [ __ ]
me
yeah i remember telling you kids on me
she was cute too
real cute how much older was she a
couple years not that a couple years
yeah like i said it's a couple years
like i said he was tiny
she was like four foot 11
little bitty
thing and she was just out of college
so would that have been maybe like 22 23
maybe you see that's not that weird i
mean like i said it's not advisable in
brazil man [ __ ] anything i mean
yeah but i'm just saying that it's like
if
you know if you really wanted to date
that person all you have to do is like
wait for them to graduate and then it's
not weird because everybody's like free
but you know it's weird if it's like
like i said like an 18 year old girl and
like a 45 year old man yeah it's a
little bit creepy see she knew what she
was doing because she waited
she waited for the [ __ ] last like
day three the last day of school
okay well you know what i'm not yeah
yeah if i can finish that show [ __ ]
we we did the last and now by the way i
love you yeah and she
backstage and she ran behind me nobody
was there she [ __ ] ran across me and
[ __ ] put her arms around me and
[ __ ] planted a big old [ __ ] lip
lock on me tongue and everything
i was like yeah and then she took off
she couldn't resist never again she
couldn't resist that rick springfield
energy that you had
didn't have that haircut i'm sorry
that's just what i think of every time i
thought i'd have this first time with
that rick springfield and jessie's girl
my hair my hair was a lot shorter then
[Laughter]
yeah it is granthar said he actually had
a doctorate degree high school was
probably not his first career choice
maybe that's why yeah maybe he's like
what the [ __ ] am i doing with my life
yeah right like teaching all these
[ __ ] losers like [ __ ] loser
teenagers he's teaching [ __ ] algebra
so you know yeah he's like i could have
had a real job but no
teaching is a real job that's just maybe
probably not what he wanted to do uh
zach says finally finish the autism show
still so mad i missed the live show yeah
we were wondering why you didn't show up
because that i thought i was missing
that money zach well no because
because you were the one that that
suggested it that topic and it was like
a really good topic and it actually
ended up being a good show i thought
yeah but uh so we just the whole time we
were just kind of like where's zach
i got some good [ __ ] stories uh good
wesley stories in that in that show all
that's just true the weird [ __ ] he would
do
well you know
wesley
and well yeah cause zach messaged me
earlier and said i kind of want to meet
wesley now yeah
you should well i could give you a sk
you could you should hook them up you
should hook them up on facebook or
something because he yeah like wesley
likes to talk to people yeah on facebook
he'll he'll like uh he'll like phone
call you a little you know video call
you
at odd hours just telling you he hasn't
done that to me in a while but he used
to
um
yeah granthar said bob ross was a master
sergeant the air force said he started
painting because he was tired of yelling
at 19 year olds yeah he's a fascinating
fascinating dude i love that
yeah he was like a drill sergeant or
something like that and which you never
even think of because he's just so
calm and relaxing and everything like
that but that's exactly why he went like
that because he's like yeah i don't want
to be that person anymore and he just
like [ __ ]
chilled right the [ __ ] out and even to
this day
all these decades later people are still
like watching the bob ross thing
and they even have like bob ross like
merchandise which i didn't realize until
i watched that documentary that's on
netflix
but the thing about it is that bob
ross's thank you
uh estate
they didn't really authorize that but
because of this whole there's i mean
this uh documentary goes all into it but
it's like the the legal ramification of
like using his name and his image and
stuff like that
um maybe not what he would have wanted
but after he passed away like the people
that were his partners and maybe
i don't know they were kind of like
maybe shitty people it's perhaps and
they were just kind of like hey we're
gonna you know make money off his name
and his image so
you can go and like [ __ ] a [ __ ]
mall store like fye and they have like
bob ross like lunch boxes and [ __ ] like
that which is crazy
because that's some [ __ ] that i saw when
on
pbs when i was little you know what i
mean gomo kind of saying that [ __ ]
he's re-watching the classic
episode
[Laughter]
that's funny that we have classic
episodes i didn't even think of it that
way
i'm always kind of scared to go back and
listen to our old ones because i'm sure
there's i'm sure they're terrible some
of them
the recording quality is terrible i'm
sure they're talking um
although i will say some people tend to
prefer our older ones i guess because
our older ones were recorded yeah and
tended to stay more on topic and we're
more succinct i guess because nowadays
like we drink on there we're just like
growing off on all kind of tangents
and then i end up getting mad cause i'm
like i didn't even get to talk about the
topic [ __ ] and it's just like this whole
thing but i don't know it's not always
like that well no but it's like i'm
having a good time so it's all right
it's our favorite yeah zach [ __ ]
what's funny we'll tell you one thing
that's funny about wessex
is that
he hates being called autistic so you
can't say that
again i couldn't mention it in the book
he'll [ __ ] allow you to say that he's
deaf but he won't want you to say that
he's autistic
and it's because during all that [ __ ]
therapy and everything
when he would go to the deaf related
training
he wanted to be deaf
because they had hot girls in there
[Laughter]
yeah hot girls in there and they had
like normal people in there because most
deaf people are just normal people they
just can't yeah of course
but then when he would go to the autism
[ __ ] these are profoundly autistic stuff
he'd be like oh hell no i'm not one of
these oh hell no i could see that yeah
he even and but the thing is is that
well he wants to be treated like a
normal person yeah
hell no i'm not i'm not one of these
things
but then you're like no dude
that you're just like this you know it
so
yeah it's funny he he's prejudiced
against [ __ ] autistic people
based on that
yeah yeah i guess he's like these
[ __ ] are too weird
yeah but he's doing autistic stuff he's
just he's well they're not weird the
same way that he's weird and like i said
when you do [ __ ] it doesn't seem weird
to you yeah right and it's hard for you
to like get outside of yourself and say
okay
another autistic person doing the same
kind of [ __ ] he does but he just do it
in a different way he's like oh that's
it's weird man no i'm not like that
but then he'll go right around and
[ __ ]
[ __ ] look at knot holes or something
you know
[Laughter]
he's not as bad as he was but uh when he
was a kid well like i said he's your age
now yeah when he was a kid he was
[ __ ] did all kinds of [ __ ] thank you
zach
uh i'll probably stick to chat with
wesley because i know as much about sign
language as i do about that african
clicking language
he can't spell all that well i uh i
started learning sign language a long
time ago i don't remember why i i just
kind of felt like oh well oh no i
remember why because
when i was a teenager uh i had constant
ear infections
and i had to go to the doctor i was on
all kind of medication for my constant
ear infections my ears would bleed and
all this other kind of stuff and i
remember very distinctly going to a
doctor and being like well
you'll probably be deaf or you know
mostly deaf before you're in your 20s
so i thought to myself
it's like that's not good and i was like
maybe i should start learning sign
language so i did actually kind of start
learning it but happily i didn't go
completely i'm not
i'm not uh
deaf deaf i can't hear all that well um
especially if there's other noises like
especially if there's like a noise over
there and it's like so i always have to
put like closed captioning on and stuff
um if there's a lot of other noise i
can't
hear what you're saying it just sounds
like the
it just sounds like that um
so but i but i can still hear well
enough i don't need sign language but i
did like start learning it because of
that reason uh thank you guamo khan
i've been meaning to donate to you guys
since i first came across channel many
years ago better late than never i
suppose well thank you very much that's
very nice of you
uh
murder hornet return says more advice if
cops knock on your door and never step
outside
yeah i mean i kind of feel like
i've written enough true crime to know
that there's like some serial killers
out there that pretend to be cops and
like knock on your door yeah i'm a cop
i'm just like yeah i don't believe that
sorry you're gonna have to come in here
and get me i'm not coming out there no
way
um
buddy data says show on people who were
born from donor sperm who find out they
have 50 siblings
wouldn't that make okay because we've
been watching like i said sometimes at
night
like if we have to watch a movie to
review or something like that like it
sounds like it's a job it's well it kind
of is but i don't mind it
so after we usually like watch whatever
we have to watch
then i'll usually
uh put like old unsolved mysteries on
because there's just something really
relaxing it's just kind of like a
haunting you know i like the music i
like robert stacks
the mellifluous voice like you know
taking me in and i can just like lay
there and kind of like doze off and
watch the mysteries and stuff
so i was watching that the other day and
i you know unsolved mysteries back they
always had like that lost loves section
where people were like looking for lost
family members it's like oh hey i got uh
you know adopted or i'm from an
orphanage or some [ __ ] like that and
they're like looking for their family
members can you imagine
on unsolved mysteries
somebody that had been born from like
from a sperm donor and they were looking
for all of the other siblings that had
been born from the same sperm toner
that would be [ __ ] funny there had to
well i mean you know
there has to have been something like
that
how weird would that be like if you went
and you went to a sperm donation clinic
and
they used your sperm like on a whole
bunch of different people and like a
whole bunch of different people have
been saying you wouldn't even know about
it thank you very much gummica
that's crazy
yeah
dc says yeah you seem to hear tom fine
yeah there's no other noise in here
there's no other noise in here the only
time i start having problems is if
there's other noise zach go ahead zach's
sending more money thanks thank you zach
i'm so much happier inviting other
autistic people into my friend or dating
pool so much more in common and the sex
is mind-blowing oh wow
[Laughter]
you don't want to come after wes with
the [ __ ] gay angle
he'll probably he'll probably [ __ ]
get scared
he'll probably get he's like oh hell no
oh hell no i haven't talked to wes in a
long time he used to like duct tape on
his booty
he used to like try to call me all the
time well because remember
i knew who he was because of you telling
me about the mammoth mountain story like
i said he lives in california so i've
never like met them you met him in
person because you're my girlfriend he
thinks he's related he thinks that
you're related to him so he's gonna call
you right so yeah so he just kind of
thought like after like when we first
started like going out we've been going
out for like a year or two like he would
start to like call me and at first i
wasn't sure like i'm like who is this
person that's like trying to call me
and then tom's just like oh that's my
cousin wesley you know you know i've
told you about him yeah and he's just
trying to like call me like all the time
which i thought was like really funny
and he would always just kind of like
comment on our photos and yeah stuff
like that yeah i don't even know is he
on facebook anymore i don't know i don't
really see him he doesn't like interact
with anything like i put up
grandma's topics brazilian women crazy
actor is it intentional or just part of
the yeah part of the culture
um couple different
oh man
[Music]
there are different classes of
of of people in brazil all right and
brazilian rich girls are a [ __ ] pain
in the ass all right
uh real pampered
uh snotty
uh [ __ ] uh perfectionist types
and then you have kind of like the
working class type girls and they're
about moving up in this world you know
but they've got standards too you know
well everyone needs to have standards
let's not hate on girls i saw
there's a video of a guy his name is
[ __ ] i forgot that guy's name
sabbatical is the channel it's on uh
youtube
and he goes all over the world goes to
africa goes to europe and [ __ ] he
ended up in brazil recently
and he's walking around he speaks a
couple different languages and he can he
can make himself understood pretty well
in portuguese
based on his spanish
and um he's walking around with his cell
phone and [ __ ] you know
going through a working-class
neighborhood
in in down south in brazil
which is kind of a little bit more of a
germanic type area
um
and some uh girls see him speaking
english and jump on him and say come on
we'll we'll
show you around the neighborhood like on
a tour all right
and they take him to the store and
they get something to eat and he pays
and then you know
they don't spend much money
and then they kind of
he's talking to the phone and following
them around and then finally they go go
back and go you stay here
we we're going
he's like oh okay say dump him
bye you've outlived your usefulness
well that was weird
i was like you don't know brazilian
girls
okay it wasn't weird they [ __ ]
sized you up and go this dude's not hot
this dude's not hot looking and he's not
paying any attention to us he's talking
to that phone too much and um he didn't
have i get that that's interesting yeah
and he he didn't have he didn't have the
correct social skills for brazil
brazil you got to be on your game all
the time you know and you have to be
entertaining
and uh
high energy yeah that's right dance
pretty big yeah dance for me [ __ ]
it's like that kind of stuff
and because he didn't pay enough
attention to them
and he he was too american which is kind
of too stiff and
not didn't work didn't work and they
they they gave him a good opening move
you know what i mean they [ __ ] hey
like oh what's up pokemon
cookie jumped through the [ __ ] did
you scare her yeah she's got scared
she's like what are you doing daddy quit
waving
and then they
they hit him and [ __ ] [ __ ] come on
we're gonna show you around there they
were they were cute girls they were
young though they were young they were
17 18. and he's
30 maybe
but
a brazilian 18 year old is kind of like
an american 25 year old
a brazilian 16 year old is like a
like a brazilian as a brazilian 16 year
old is like an american 20 year old
a lot of brazilian girls are married
at 16 17.
you know and have kids depending on what
their
uh social class is i guess you could say
what their income levels are where we're
talking about a lot of them
they snap them hotties up [ __ ] early
they're pregnant
fast
murder hornet asked what how the cocaine
was in brazil
um expensive hard to get quality not
that good stepped on it a lot cook it
brazil is not a drug place
well it's legal there is it not no where
it was wasn't it no [ __ ] highly
illegal oh okay what am i thinking of
well uh when you go up north you know
places like [ __ ] peru
and bolivia they it's yeah there it's
wide open
maybe colombia
is i think that's semi i think it's
illegal in columbia but they're making a
lot of it
uh brazil
weed can get you into serious trouble
in brazil during the time i was there
what was wide open was alcohol they
didn't care how old you were
you know i kind of feel like a lot of
europe is going to like that too okay
i get up in the morning and [ __ ] go
to the [ __ ]
luncheon at you to get a [ __ ]
breakfast it's called a vitamins it's
like a smoothie made out of damn
brazilian fruit
and avocado
with guava
and everything and creamy deleci and
beautiful [ __ ]
smoothie drinks
brazil was on to the smoothie things for
going all the way back to the 70s or the
60s okay
so i could get one of those you go in
there and be like a brazilian
working street kid you know
who pushes a damn cart and picks up all
the garbage and [ __ ] collects all and
he's like eight
runner and
smoking cigarettes and [ __ ] ordering
alcohol first thing in the morning
i'd give them a [ __ ] pausing which is
like a little thing of french bread you
know cause they don't hardly have any
money but they all work
poor people work there i wonder how long
that kid lives they live as
no that's part of the life cycle they
can live for a long time
60s and 70s
it's like something i mean i kind of
feel like if an eight-year-old kid got
to work for a living then
if they want to drink or smoke then yeah
so it's basically how they're saying and
that's totally illegal totally illegal
but brazilian society goes he's working
for a living yes yeah you know that's
okay because he's a favela kid yeah you
know
and you know it's better than running
around stealing
so uh
that little kid was treated like an
adult
and it was like something you'd see here
in the united states out of the 30s or
the 20s yeah because that happened here
that was that's the same thing because
little kids were working little kids
were working
smoking and drinking
you know and it was like
something out of [ __ ] you know the
industrial revolution of the europe of
the you know [ __ ] late 1800s you know
kids and mine mine shafts and [ __ ] same
thing so i've seen it by myself
and um
i i approve in a certain way
it's better that poor kids are like that
than poor kids [ __ ]
running around feral on drugs and
selling drugs and [ __ ] you know what i
mean like you could trust that kid
you know i mean you could loan him money
he says look if i give you this and this
and that will do this that you could cut
a deal with him and he keep his end of
the bargain
i see him all the time
well because they're like i said they're
like an adult like an adult because yeah
yeah so
that for all i know that kid grew up to
be successful
because he had a lot of hunger
to
come up in life you know
natural selection
grand theft auto says best way to treat
common stds that was another question
oh i don't know man i'm not a doctor
bless you i can't give medical advice
she sneezed
benny hinn miracle healer or of diseases
or charlatan uh you guys know the answer
to that question charlatan
is that [ __ ] still alive
i kind of feel like i used to watch him
because i used to hate watch like a lot
of those televangelists because i
thought they were kind of like funny but
also like how the [ __ ] do people send
these people money i don't get it zack
is asking for a good brazilian movie
there's one of them i can come up on top
of my head called kiss of the spider
woman you'll love it oh that was a good
movie
yeah it's about a tran it's about a
brazilian transsexual in prison back in
the 80s
and she's telling you this story
it's because it's called kiss the spider
yeah that was that's a classic flick the
other one was a brazilian um
uh horror movie comedy horror movie so
what was that yeah what was that that
was the one that i was thinking of um
yeah it was kind of like it was called
ghost hunters versus bloody mary or
something like that
it was something like that yeah you'll
love that that was hysterical see it
with [ __ ] super gory and like super
super funny see it with subtitles
it's like a 80s
it's like a sam raimi like a san remy
80s they've seen all the movies you've
seen they've seen that
and they're going to [ __ ] talk about
those movies but they're going to see
horror movies bring all the world
together the whole world together right
everybody loves the same horror movies
yeah we're all the same species that's
good and they're all like i i just i
don't know why that makes me so happy
but it's like every time i see
a movie from
a country that you don't usually see
horror movies from and it's like
obviously they've been watching all the
same they love evil dead and they just
love all that kind of stuff and like
they want to make a horror movie too and
so they make it and i'm just like ah
that's so cool that's so cool but yeah
so
that's a really good one we saw that on
netflix no netflix shutter shutter i
think it was on shutter sure i don't
know if it's on shutter anymore but it
was for a while yeah it goes
what was it called ghost hunters versus
bloody mary or something like that
something like that it was brazilian
malcolm says reminding my cousins my
neighborhood friends in mexico they do
little jobs around town they chill after
work with a beer i always thought it was
cool yeah brazil's the same way
yeah and i mean
i'm honestly not averse
when i was a little kid
it wasn't weird
because sometimes kids would be like hey
your dad would be drinking like my
parents didn't really drink but you know
my grandparents didn't either but i know
some kid's parents did and it was just
kind of like so if you had in the house
they're like hey i want to try some of
that and nobody thought it was weird to
be like here kid have some beer you know
what i mean yeah that's not terrible as
long as it's like in your house well
that particular kid would buy a pack of
cigarettes [ __ ] and uh people give
him a shot and then he'd buy a shot and
everybody liked him because he worked
you know where and he was young
and
so everybody helped him when they saw
him
the big difference in helping somebody
that does not help in themselves and
then you see a guy who's trying to this
little kid's [ __ ] trying to move
ahead and everybody's like here man
you're here yeah i mean i'd give him a
[ __ ] ponzino and give him a [ __ ]
[ __ ] little bread with some [ __ ]
uh what we call a little bread or a
little french roll with uh some ham and
some cheese and butter
you know so you can get them for like a
couple but give them that
you know it wasn't everybody kind of did
that
you know you know buy him something
when you see him then he'd start pushing
that card around pick picking up
collecting garbage
which is i'm sure something that most
people wouldn't want to do
no so there's a cart that had [ __ ]
like volkswagen bug tires on it and an
axle and a [ __ ] wooden cart and you
got in there and he'd have [ __ ] stuff
that he was collecting out of the
garbage and stuff that could be recycled
that's what he did you know like back in
the old days like in victorian london
and [ __ ] like that
you always had to have those people that
would go around in the middle of the
night and they'd have to like clean up
everyone's poop from like the
from them dumping their [ __ ]
right
their [ __ ] their what do you call
these things the
chamber pots the chamber pots like out
the windows he was going out on trash
day and going through the garbage and
finding what could be
salvaged yeah that's what he was doing
and then taking it to places recycling
places and getting money off of it yeah
like i said they just kids did that in
victorian england as well they'd go
through like
everybody's garbage and [ __ ] like that
like looking for valuable [ __ ] right
uh thank you very much mrs evans already
party that's one of my favorite uh
screen names by the way please do more
paranormal shows i even missed the old
haunting episode
we should actually talk yeah because i
still have we haven't covered all those
damn that's that's that's thank you for
watching we should actually bring me
that um
that notebook right there
and a pen from right there i got so
i gotta write i got the whole series on
video yeah i bought them for them a long
time ago we need to like look into that
and look at which ones we haven't done
because there's like a lot of good cases
on there yeah
and i we actually should do another one
because i'm running out of like
paranormal stuff
i'm going to do the haunting episode
that's funny that
it's good to hear that uh you guys are
going all the way that far back in the
catalog back when we do haunting
episodes
those used to be actually flake fun to
do yeah they were fun to do
because we
because we would kind of goof on the
episodes even though i love those
episodes i do too like but we
we pick on them because we love them
yeah we love them i don't really like
believe all of them
i think some of them were fully [ __ ] but
yeah
it was or maybe they were mistaken
they've
yeah
spun things and blown things out of
proportion in certain times
best one was haunting the summer when
yeah we did do a show actually we did a
couple shows on that yeah
but uh but the more i heard about more i
looked at the summer wind [ __ ]
mansion and the more i heard about it
more skeptical i got about it
although the people that were there were
very credible you know they they
they talked like they believed it
so who am i i mean [ __ ] i've seen
some [ __ ] weird ass [ __ ] too
it's just that the house
what i remember about summer when
is that the house wasn't as impressive
as i
was imagining yeah it really did believe
that the house is pretty impressive the
way that it looked in the episode yeah
uh if you looked the way that it looked
in the episode and the way that it
looked in real life you're like those
are two completely different things yeah
i mean it looked like
it was a mansion but it looked like a
[ __ ] hole it really looked like falling
down
you probably should have just torn it
down and started over to be honest it
didn't look like oh we can just like
knock out a couple walls and put up some
wallpaper and everything will be like
kosher it really did not look like that
the whole thing about
well they wouldn't even come out and
look at the house they wouldn't work on
things oh that house
well when you see the house that they're
talking about yeah it's like probably
it probably wasn't because it was
haunted it was probably just kind of
like yeah now
does those guys those guys were
professionals and knew that that house
was not worth
really anything it you could
you would could sink money into that
forever and not have anything
there
if you were smart you'd tear that house
down and just build another one yeah i
do kind of feel like that's what that's
that probably would have been the best
way to go about that like it was a cool
looking how i'm sure it was a
cool-looking house one time at one time
but by the time they bought it it was in
such terrible shape yeah it was that i
really don't think it would have been
worth it no to refurbish she should have
just like torn it down and started it
right so what the contractors are doing
are like oh yeah if you're in that piece
of [ __ ] you don't have any money and you
don't really want to sink any money in
that because that shit's on its way out
and those guys know what they're talking
about
you can go and look at some of these
urbex videos urban exploration videos on
youtube
and see [ __ ] beautiful mansions
guys will go in there and they'll
do an exploration and they're still mint
a lot of them are still furnished they
got people's stuff in them they just
left their [ __ ] there yeah and it's been
in there for [ __ ] 10 15 years
and it's just looks brand new
and you're like well what's wrong why
isn't this selling it's because
the mansion market is a very very tough
market
if you can afford a mansion you can
afford to build a mansion of course so
why the [ __ ] would you [ __ ] have buy
somebody else's mansion
that's a waste of time that's what i'm
saying the same amount of money you can
build your own
so
that's the problem in most places of the
us maybe not in some prime real estate
or whatever you know somewhere out in
[ __ ] beverly hills it's not that same
situation well and it depends on what
you're looking for like maybe you want
something that has like a lot of history
behind it or something like that but
if you have the money like lik if i was
a millionaire yeah and i could build
whatever the [ __ ] i wanted yeah i'm
probably not gonna buy somebody else's
old [ __ ] i'm gonna have somebody build
something exactly how i want it right i
mean and most people probably would once
you get into the mansion market there
aren't that many people in the mad
mansion market but there are a lot of
mansions so there's a lot of empty
mansions
and if you're in the mansion market you
don't want to you don't want to use
mansion you want a new mansion for about
the same price so a mansion will sit
forever
strange but true it'll just sit there
there's no resale in that
there's a lot poor people and i'm gonna
consider ourselves be in that thing
we're poor people too um i am absolutely
a poor person
well i'll buy this mansion and then i'll
resell it and make a million no you
won't
no you won't
i never for a second thought that no way
now a smaller house where there's a lot
of buyers yeah you you can
you can flip it and make money on that
but you can't make it that and you can't
make any money on a mansion
not unless it's a maybe a mansion that a
famous person owned and it's in a prime
real estate yeah if it had like some
history behind it or if it was like in
some kind of historical area where
people are looking for that but yeah but
no if it's in a place where a lot of new
stuff is being built absolutely not no
uh it's just kind of like you have
people thinking well i'll buy this
[ __ ] sports car and this ferrari and
it will be an investment no well
it will [ __ ] depreciate in value cars
are very rarely an investment
unless they're collectible inside
and when that thing's 10 years old it's
worth a fraction
none of these rich ferrari [ __ ]
want it
and you try to sell it
you go to try to sell it you'll never
get a satisfactory price for it so they
just sit around
you know now when it's 50 years old or
60 years old and there aren't many of
them left it can become a classic sure
but the thing is is that that's after
you're dead yeah so
i mean if you're gonna do collectibles
there's particular things like i said
did james dean die in this car no then
nobody wants it
nobody wants it sorry there's no
historical value right uh like i said
unless it's completely refurbished and
it's like an antique and it's very very
old and it's still like in running
condition then yeah you might be able to
get some [ __ ] for it then but
uh other than that yeah becca said
watched haunting in connecticut a few
years ago like 1am yeah
rebecca says winchester mystery house
and the queen mary would be great shows
didn't we do we did a winchester mystery
house show did we not oh yeah we did a
show i'm pretty sure we did and i
thought we did a queen mary one but
although i could be wrong i'm
99 sure we did a winchester mystery
house yeah
all right brad jones has asked me
whether he needs help with the program i
don't know what program you're talking
about or what kind of help you need do
you i need more context bro well he will
thank you
he's going to tell you maybe it's one of
the programs we did i don't know
guamacon says you guys explanation of
paranormal stuff is rspk for a lot of
these stories and cases really changed
my perspective on stuff good yeah i mean
oh our rspk is a reality
i've seen it i'm gonna run to the
bathroom it's just that it's rare
it's very rare and uh
but it's evidently has reared its head
many times over the millennia
because uh a lot of that stuff that
[ __ ]
you hear about you know the
yin force and yang force
and the chinese talking about
swordsmen that have abilities
you know that's where they got all that
[ __ ] from [ __ ]
star wars you know star wars was born
borrowed you know borrowed from all that
uh
that's what they're talking about
you know china was around for [ __ ] a
long time so
and they were literate for a long time
so they recorded poltergeist activity
but they just kind of had their own
cultural spin on it
now that doesn't mean everything that
chinese said is true because they
believed their chinese medicine is full
of [ __ ]
uh
in general
although we'll say this
after my motorcycle accident when i was
in the army they sent me to brazil
because that's where my actual legal
residence was at the time
for convalescence
and uh i was having real [ __ ] bad
back pains
and had a brazilian doctor he's half
brazilian have chinese
and his name is dr thiago
and uh i went in there for a special
kind of acupuncture treatment
that worked they were sticking he was
sticking needles in my back
and then attaching uh
electrodes to him and shocking certain
muscle groups
and it worked man it it actually kind of
relaxed certain
areas of my back and [ __ ] um
he repositioned uh
tendons and popped him into place and it
was kind of like massage also
and it uh it
he straightened my back out kind of like
chiropractic chiropractioner and
and stimulating muscles
working them to exhaustion
which you would think like what the hell
would that well your body's recuperative
abilities are going to be
going to go to the areas that were hyper
stimulated it worked
it worked
so certain certain aspects he was using
real modern high-tech acupuncture on me
but they were using electrical
stimulation too
it worked
but a lot of therapies work it's just a
therapy
yeah
brad says weight gain and strength
training i don't want to disrupt the
show but how can i reach out
uh oh
who's who's talking about brad jones
brad jones asking you about like weight
training and stuff okay
probably the best thing to be like
contact you on facebook because that's
usually how you uh yeah you give me get
me on uh get me on messenger i can talk
i'll talk to you more about it but uh
he's under thomas ross
yeah everything has to do or you can
find me through context on jenny's page
or the 13 o'clock page you'll be able to
find me on there
but um
in general
um
i don't know how old you are or how much
you weigh it's gonna it depends on what
what your situation is right now and
what it is you're looking for
every person is different
but uh yeah weight training
lift weights always i don't know how old
you are but always
lift weights
and eat right
and try to lose fat
try to gain muscle
by any means necessary if you're in your
second half for life go on hrt
uh don't if your teeth fall out replace
your teeth with false teeth if your
hormones stop flowing replace those
hormones with synthetic hormones hormone
replacement therapy yes
hugo says you did a show about
winchester house yeah i thought we did
yeah yeah we did uh it's one of my
favorite shows i liked tom's input he
was on point that was actually like a
really fun show to do i remember
because that is like some uh [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ]
right there that house
honestly i would actually like to go
there in person and see that [ __ ]
that winchester house
that's in california yeah
you've never been to it though
no
i would actually like to go to it i
don't i don't think she was
i don't think uh that she was crazy or
thought it was ghosts or anything like
that i think she had other reasons i
think she was lonely and we just wanted
shot and wanted to shop
yeah and she's just kind of like having
to try this [ __ ] out yeah i get it and
she has all these cute guys in the house
working all the time so she can
socialize yeah it might have been and
yeah you know how old ladies get yeah
well i think she started that one even
when she wasn't old yeah but that's a
good way of getting people to pay
attention to her and then she could go
out and talk to the workmen and go make
him stuff and go look and see and talk
and
because you know there was nowhere to go
in those days
especially for a woman of her age where
is she going to go yeah her
at her she was real interested in
different uh architectural styles and
stuff like that so she had the money so
she was just kind of like hey i'm gonna
try this [ __ ] out and see how that works
she what she was doing was them
kind of like in in the modern
terminology she was doing online
shopping
you sit here with your tablet in your
phone and you shop online
and buy things
that's what she's doing she's at home
shopping and buying things yeah yeah
which they could do back then yeah
before they had
you know before everyone could do that
you have to have an excuse for it so you
bring in the new age stuff
and that was like the that was like the
all the rage back in those days
so she's like seances and
yeah and honestly i love that kind of
[ __ ] yeah
i love all that kind of like i don't
believe any of it i think a lot of all
of it was fake but
just the whole aesthetic of it i love
the whole time period of like the 1920s
when everybody was like super into
spiritualism yeah and they're all having
seances and like harry houdini shows up
to like debunk that [ __ ] i love all that
kind of stuff i love all that that's
what she was doing yeah she's probably
the kind of chick to walk around in the
black
dress you know veils and [ __ ]
yeah she's she's a protocol yeah
and she'd look at the weird architecture
and the [ __ ] that she built she'd walk
through there with candles and [ __ ]
by herself see that's that's why i don't
think it's that weird because i'm like
that sounds like some [ __ ] i would do
yeah if i was alive back then if i was
that in that situation i wouldn't
believe in ghosts or anything like that
but i would be doing that [ __ ] totally
if i had the money well there was there
was only so many ways you could
entertain yourself back in the 80s
that's what i'm saying right that's what
i'm saying you had to like think of some
[ __ ] yeah so she invented there was no
movies or
you know there was no internet yeah
you could read books and stuff which is
cool because i still do that now but her
whole thing was to have guys come over
and work on the house
yeah build her some cool [ __ ] she'd walk
around in it
it has to to be honest with you it has
to have been for certain types of women
back then it was probably really
frustrating because i kind of feel like
you were really like limited
in what you could do you weren't really
allowed to have like jobs
or you weren't really allowed and
especially even if you had money and
stuff like that you were just kind of
like you were just sort of expected to
sort of stay home
and
sit around yeah you know what i mean so
i imagine they got like really bored
yeah i imagine they got really bored
yeah so they were kind of like coming up
with all kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
to entertain themselves the women that
had a lot of money so sure she was in a
very different
situation than most women over time true
true
okay gramthers has some more topic
suggestions i love these these are
always really good i have to say
best goth music for romance time okay i
got some answers for that how to get
into the porn industry oh okay that's i
don't know if i have too much experience
in that area but uh we'll we'll do our
best
best places to have your great minute
matches spread worst first date you ever
had
these are super good all right
best goth music for romance time i kind
of feel like for me i feel like the best
music like that is more you want
something more like ethereal goth you
want like some like dead can dance
or
i don't know like die form you want
something with like maybe some more like
operatic kind of action going on
maybe
uh i kind of feel like maybe that's kind
of a better thing
uh just generally i don't know if that's
what i would pick but that's in general
it's probably good how to get into the
porn industry um
nowadays it's probably really easy all
you gotta do is like [ __ ] turn your
webcam on and do whatever the [ __ ]
but
porn industry again because the internet
isn't what it was so i kind of feel like
it's sort of like a microcosm i guess of
the whole hollywood thing uh just as
there are no more i don't i don't know
if i want to say there are no more like
movie stars because obviously there
still are there are still stars everyone
knew who they are but
i kind of feel like porn is like the
there it's like an adjective that
because everything has been democratized
because everybody can make their own
porn nowadays and put it online and make
money off of it
uh it's proliferated to a to a degree
where it's really really hard to even
though everybody can do it which is good
but consequently it's much much harder
to get noticed
so
to be honest uh if you want to get into
porn like i said i don't really have any
experience in this area but i would
suggest
finding an underserved niche
uh underserved fetish and going in that
direction because if you're trying to do
like mainstream kind of [ __ ]
you're gonna get lost in all the noise
because there's so much [ __ ] porn
everybody can do their own porn nowadays
and millions of people are
so you really have to like tailor your
[ __ ] to like a very specialized
clientele tony and elena my ex
they did they made money doing porn with
tom it was a fetish about drowning
where that's what i mean you need to
find a niche that's not real widespread
tony would pretend to drown her
and they'd fill her way like she was
like he was drowning
and they had [ __ ] dudes paying for
that
yeah um i you know i and i kind of um
knew a girl who was doing uh webcams and
stuff like that
uh of like puppet porn which like i said
is popular well it's it's a niche but
there's a niche for there's a there's a
market for that you just have to find
something that is not
that well if you just try to do like
regular porn like look and i'm sexy and
blah blah yeah you're not going to get
anywhere with that because everybody
everybody is doing that [ __ ] so you
really need to like find unless you're
very physically talented
and even then i mean there's so much
competition there's so much competition
so i think like it's better and this
doesn't just apply to porn this applies
to everything
if you want to make money online or you
know doing whatever you're doing
whatever creative endeavor
don't try to focus on making everybody
watch your [ __ ] because that's not going
to happen there's too much competition
you really really have to target stuff
to a specific niche that is underserved
um so you got to just find find some
[ __ ] that you're really into
whatever your fetish is or something
like that no matter how weird it seems
do some [ __ ] like that
i guarantee you there's an audience out
there for that whatever it is no matter
how weird it is as long as it's not
illegal
um do that and
you'll probably like have a better time
i'm not gonna say you're gonna get rich
doing that you i'm sure you won't but
you might make a living at it
most of them are just making extra money
yeah don't think that you're gonna like
make but but like i said i think it's
more
it's more believable that you at least
make a living not a great living
but you might like squeak by
but i think it's better if you do like
target marketing don't try to be all
things to all people don't try to appeal
to a mainstream audience because
there's just too much competition
there's just too much
like i said it's not just porn it's
everything yeah books movies anytime
everybody is putting their own big porn
students are gone which like i said
that's good because it's you know it's
democratic everybody's putting their
[ __ ] up there
um
but there's so much you know
consequently there's so much noise that
it's hard to stand out so you're really
personalized though now yeah you're
really so you really need to like
hone in on something you're really into
what do i really want to do
even if it's not like widely you just go
on you go on just do that you just go on
instagram
and [ __ ] look at the instagram models
and you see that those girls all have
[ __ ] link trees that lead to other
things that they're selling
some of that stuff is
porn type stuff
but the girl starts off as just
marketing something that might be that
you're into like she might be television
movie reviews
or movie reactions but she also has a
link tree that goes back what she does
she's so it's targeted to their fans
yeah so it's not hanging out in
cyberspace and like a lot of these
fitness girls and people in the fitness
industry
that are on instagram
yeah they get big and [ __ ] and they're
[ __ ] they're they're actually
personal trainers and they're selling
training
uh packages to other girls but you
follow them back they got the link tree
and some of that [ __ ] goes to instagram
they're not instagram uh
[ __ ] what's the what's the word i'm
thinking of i don't know
only fans goes back to only fans and
they actually have
[ __ ] solo [ __ ]
videos of them [ __ ] doing themselves
and doing all kinds of weird [ __ ]
that it's not that's not their main
income
it's many income streams coming out of
that person that's another thing you
need to diversify yeah yeah and honestly
once you get a fan base yeah you kind of
have to be like well
if i have this fan base that likes me
because of
my horror movie reviews for example
um then maybe for special people i can
sell them this other thing hey here's a
video of me jerking off like you know
what i mean you know it's i'm not doing
that but i'm just saying yeah that you
can do that they're do they are doing it
because they like you as a person they
like you as a personality because they
know you first so they feel like i know
you through your [ __ ] so i kind of feel
like that's probably the way to go about
it like i said you're probably not going
to get rich that way some people do i'm
sure
but make a living though you could
probably make a living you know like i
said you're not going to get dependent
on the person depending on the person
now
this is great of course because it cuts
out all the parasitical middle men that
used to be around
the old school porn industry of the 70s
and the 80s and the 90s when you had to
[ __ ] hire dudes with cameras and all
this equipment and all this [ __ ] those
dudes were [ __ ] parasites
all right
uh they've
they basically owned those girls they
got a very little
they paid they paid the girl next to
nothing and then they turn around
and [ __ ] make a lot off of those
videos it's great that it's democratized
now through technology that girl gets
most of her money
well she can make her own movies she
make her own she doesn't have to hire
some creepy ass [ __ ] to make it
dude in the privacy of her own home and
yeah you might have a tech platform take
a cut but so be it because they're
providing her yeah that's okay which is
to bring that to i am totally not
bothered like i said i publish my own
books i publish my own podcast and i
have to pay right you know i pay you
know monthly fees i pay like [ __ ] like
that i pay a cut like every time
somebody buys a book or something but
i don't mind that because it's like hey
that's a platform that i never had
before
i couldn't do that on my own it was
access
yeah well uh yeah i wanted to like five
bucks thank you zach my favorite thing
that's been democratized is filmmaking
the fact that you can shoot a movie on
your phone these days amazing to me
honestly i think that's awesome and as i
said
uh anytime you have something like that
like i said now that the technology is
so cheap
um
yeah 90 of the stuff is going to be crap
but
90 of the [ __ ] was always crap yeah and
now some of the shit's really good and
honestly i've seen some indie movies
like or some indie music stuff like
people just recorded [ __ ] in their house
and stuff like that was [ __ ] amazing
well another thing another thing that's
been democratized is music videos
uh i've been listening to
music videos from a from a ch on a
channel on youtube
that is it's called omf o'keefe
musicals something or other
and
it's kind of like a school a music
school for young people
okay so it's kids like school of rock
and they make videos
oh that's cool
and a lot of them are teenagers all
right
and man i was listening to one of them
[ __ ] um you guys can find it on
uh
on on
youtube it's called
i think it's
eight-year-old kills it
um on [ __ ] freak on a leash corn
freak on a leash cover
and it's it's actually the band is
teenage guys the garage band and they
[ __ ] kill it they're really good
guitarist and [ __ ] and the drummer's
a little kid
but one of those little sisters out
there playing hopscotch in the front in
the on the driveway and she goes into
the garage and all of a sudden starts
doing
corn and she's [ __ ] kills it she
kills it and she's eight
and that channel kids kick ass right
they can and the video is shot in the
garage
with i guess probably just a phone
probably but the way it's edited it's
better than anything that we had in the
80s i love it and i love it girl [ __ ]
kills it [ __ ] singing corn
i love it and that same channel has a
bunch of kids doing stuff uh
nine-year-old girls singing [ __ ]
thunder kiss 65 a zombie
rock a [ __ ] white zombie cover
and it's oh i've seen that but yeah
that's yeah and it's like the older
brothers are [ __ ] doing all the
[ __ ]
you know see how [ __ ] cool is that
and they how [ __ ] it became kind of
like a thing to have your little sister
come in sure and do the vocals you know
what i mean on these [ __ ] really
heavy songs yeah and it works it works
it's funny it's funny but you can still
jam to it sure you're like you know
[Laughter]
see like my ass is old and i think
that's like [ __ ] awesome i think
that's awesome yeah and then they walk
off then they walk off and get on a
tricycle and
they get on the big wheel and ride away
so it's funny and well and i've never
been
self-aware enough to do that yeah like
like
look i'm still a little kid yeah yeah
yeah here's the hat yeah and then like
in the background you see the neighbors
are jamming out
because it's done in the neighborhood
sorry well back in the day that would
cost [ __ ] hundreds of thousands of
dollars to produce something like that
now you can do it for nothing and all
your neighbors would have complained
they'd be complaining and then you look
and it's got like 2.4 million views
because come on who doesn't want to
watch that what the [ __ ]
i hear you know i mean you're like
that would have been a hit
come on that's awesome and then in the
early mtv days they'd like that have
been a hit
but see the thing about i mean some of
these new kids coming up man with the in
the metal scene these these kids are 14
15 16.
with these guitars they [ __ ]
kill it
really good
doing covers of [ __ ] slayer like a
war ensemble
um
reproducing perfectly
ozzy osbourne metallica covers and
they're just like god damn
i told 14 15 years it's not the same as
it used to be because there used to be
yeah before the internet was uh you know
ubiquitous
there used to be like a generational
gap yeah you know it's like oh you know
when we were kids it's like oh our
parents were like oh what is this
nonsense blah blah blah so it was just
kind of like that like if less so in our
generation i think generation x was kind
of the first one that our parents were
still kind of like cool with it they
didn't you know but and they were still
kind of like using the technology too it
wasn't like as drastic
but
after
us like i kind of feel like when
generation x started having kids
um
then it got to a point where generations
became a meaningless distinction yeah
because um after the internet came along
and everything is online from forever
always
so i kind of feel like it didn't really
matter like when stuff came out because
even if you were 12
you would you could discover stuff from
like [ __ ]
1950s and you'd be like all into it yeah
that didn't matter like
yeah that's it that's the girl that
comes in and starts killing it on corn
it's [ __ ] hilarious she picks up the
[ __ ] mic and then she's
and she's scowling at the she's scowling
and [ __ ]
yeah yeah look at her ponytail yeah
oh i love it
that's so cool
yeah that's so cool yeah she's good too
yeah i love that kind of [ __ ] i love
that kind of [ __ ]
you go little girl
[Laughter]
you go little girl
see where is she
[Laughter]
i don't want to get a copyright strike
well i guess it probably wouldn't matter
because it probably would but okay
[Applause]
she's nice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
pretty good for 9.
like i said that little girl kicks ass
come on
come on
as i said i i honestly that's one of the
best things
that's one of the things i like best
about the internet is that
it's kind of impossible well it kind of
erased
all the generational uh gaps as well it
was just kind of like look everything's
on the internet now from whatever era
um
[Music]
so everyone's just kind of like free to
get into whatever the [ __ ] they want to
get into
and there's like a niche there for
everybody
so
i don't know i think that's i think
that's really cool i think that's really
cool
well
mama conan says yourself well yeah
you're yeah yeah
that's awesome yeah you should check out
a band called twin tribes twin tribes uh
we actually have seen them live a couple
of times because
uh they played at the absolution
festival in tampa which we've been to
the last couple years i usually um i do
all the graphics for them we did their
shirts
all that stuff
if you don't know in tampa
they do a three-day
gothic industrial it's not industrial
it's more like gothic
old school gothic gothic death rock dark
wave
they do a three day
festival
uh in tampa every october it's usually
early october
they didn't do one in 2020 but they've
done one uh subsequently so they're
doing one this year in october because
i'm already doing the stuff for it and
twin tribes are usually there so we've
actually seen them a couple of times
live so yeah they're actually really
good uh are a really good band
uh best places to have your cremated
ashes spread i'm not really sure about
that
i kind of feel like um i'm i'll be
beyond caring at that point so i don't
really know
i don't really know where i'd want my
ashes spread i don't think i would give
a [ __ ] either way
worst first date you've ever had
um
that's an interesting question
i've been kind of lucky and that i
haven't really had that many bad
birthdays like i've heard some horror
stories
but
i'm trying to think of like any really
like bad experiences i've had
hmm
i don't know i have like i said i
haven't had a lot of bad experiences
just because
one
um
my whole thing was that i was like
really really introverted and not all
that really interested in like dating
people
uh until i was in my early 20s at which
point i met somebody and i got married
and then so i was married for 15 years
and then when i got divorced in
2009 or 2010 i think it was
and then i started dating people and i
was like pretty lucky that i had
pretty good
um
you know experiences in that regard i
didn't like meet anybody that was like a
total weirdo i like i met a couple dudes
that were actually like pretty awesome
um and like we hung out for our time i
didn't like ever go on any dates with
anybody that was like hey this dude's a
serial killer he's gonna like [ __ ]
kidnap me or nothing like that so i'm
like i was kind of lucky in that regard
but i know that a lot of women are not
that lucky
um
i think i was only that lucky because i
was like just really introverted and
didn't really want to like
go out with many people but i was lucky
and
in that most people that i met after i
got divorced
were
were fine we're okay dudes
um you know
and i wasn't one to be like hey i'm
gonna go
with this person like i did do that a
couple times but
thankfully it worked out okay in both
situations where i did that like both
the dudes turned out to be perfectly
nice dudes so there was that too
but that doesn't always happen so watch
it out there just saying
uh
yeah um okay getting a lot of thumbs up
thank you very much for the thumbs up
people
bundy data how's your pizza hornet uh
jenny got one left on the porch until
ants got it yo that one yeah it wasn't a
pizza it was actually it was a sandwich
and a salad yeah
they were they didn't deliver for so
long that i
thought they weren't gonna come so i
ordered so like we went got chinese food
yeah
and then we got we were going out to get
the chinese food because we're gonna go
pick it up and then oh now they left the
[ __ ] food there but it was on them
but it had been there so long i mean
yeah
i didn't pay for it though because no
they were they took the money away or
they they discounted it they did well
yeah
they felt really bad they sent me like
all kind of coupons afterwards
yeah which i didn't use but honestly the
other day like when you weren't here i
was just kind of like ah what the hell
ordered from domino's again because i
was too lazy to go and get anything
yeah and i did but i i didn't do the
thing
that was like a couple weeks ago
so i got like a i just got a sandwich
but i made it so that i watched
for the driver
well they have a thing now and i don't
think they had this even a couple months
ago when i when i did that [ __ ] they
have a thing now where the it tracks the
car like to your house
which is nice
amazon started doing that too yeah do
you know that amazon's losing money now
i mean they lost two billion dollars
last year
that's some [ __ ] man
how's that possible they lost money to a
couple billion
i don't know if that was covered that
got him or what probably but a lot of
although you think that amazon
they would have been benefited from uh
kovac
isn't [ __ ] working y'all know what's
going on bro
[ __ ] a lot of people are hurting
um
yeah it's looking
disney's [ __ ]
netflix is [ __ ]
what else was [ __ ] people you guys
remember who it was
it's just yeah you know
whatever
oh man i'm gonna say that starting to
kick in alcohol are starting to kick in
yeah i've noticed yeah agnes says where
do you sell your books i'm interested um
on amazon amazon yeah um what do you do
let me tell you i'm gonna tell them
the first book you gotta get okay
is unseen hand
her compilation of all the [ __ ]
poltergeist cases that she dug up you
will love that book how how well that
book actually is rated real well steve
mara who's a british spirit psychologist
thought that was the [ __ ] best
poultry guys book you'd ever read
it's a great compilation i did a lot of
work on that yeah
well i wrote a couple books with steve
mara as well yeah those are good also
talking about his cases yeah
and i would start i would start with
unseen hand and i did some true crime
[ __ ] too that's right and the true crime
[ __ ] is good too but i was saying if
you're into the paranormal aspect of 13
o'clock get unseen hand first if you're
into the true crime version get um
faceless faceless villain seriously
three books yeah it's three volumes
right
it's unsolved murders unsolved murder is
going way back uh the first volume is
1900 to 19 yeah 59 i think
and then the second volume is 1960 to
1979 and then the third volume and we
rarely plug books on this show which we
should start plugging more
because there's a lot of sales out there
people don't even know you know what i
mean
but i [ __ ]
me and jenny we're not re we're business
minded but when we get caught up in the
show we're having fun and we forget
to plug well and to me it always seems
like here's the thing you're begging you
know that's what i'm saying yeah and
it's like i've had people tell me
people that have known me for years and
years
have come up to me like in person like
at the club like friends of ours yeah i
didn't know that you wrote books
i didn't know that you designed board
games i didn't know that you did this
and that in the other well because i
don't really i don't know i feel like
really she's not a self-promoter
right when i talk about it
i just like to do them and put them out
there if like people can find them cool
um i don't know i just feel like an
[ __ ] like talking about
[Music]
so i always kind of feel like really
embarrassed i know this is dumb but it's
like i feel really embarrassed
about
it's like yeah i've i've written like a
a [ __ ] time [ __ ] ton of books
i haven't like i've written four
paranormal type books i wrote a book
with you yeah about mammoth mountain i
wrote two books with uh steve mirror
about two of his poltergeist cases i
wrote unseen hand which was all
poltergeist cases from like uh you know
back in
you know pre-history uh and i've written
three true crime books
unsolved murders from the whole 20th
century i've also written
several novels short story compilations
i've written like a bunch of horror
fiction uh but i don't really talk about
it all that much i've also designed a
[ __ ] ton of like board games
uh many of which have to do with horror
i've done like a edgar allan poe one
i've done like a halloween one i've done
like all kind of stuff like that but
it's just kind of like i don't know
i'm more interested in
me but that's probably my downfall
honestly
i'm more interested in like making the
[ __ ]
you know what i mean it's like oh i got
this idea and i'm like i'm gonna make
the [ __ ] i'm gonna write the book i'm
gonna make this game or whatever and
then once i've done it and i'm like oh
it's done i'm gonna move on to the next
thing i don't think about like selling
it because that's not my deal yeah she's
agnes is saying she loves [ __ ]
paranormal and everything that she you
should have me plug your book that's
really what i was supposed to do i
whenever we go to [ __ ] yeah you're
falling down on the job i'm falling
[Laughter]
whenever we go to whenever we go to
[ __ ] like uh author [ __ ] seminars
and [ __ ] [ __ ] you know jenny will go
i'll go down there and i'll sell every
book she has
i'll [ __ ] sell out
in person i'm a [ __ ] compelling sales
person yeah i mean when we did
conventions
and i took my books there i'll [ __ ]
sell them he would sell every single one
of them
which is good because i don't like to do
it and i'll be like i'm just kind of
like hey you want to buy okay yeah and
i'm like
it's very hard to sell your own stuff
it's a lot yeah because you kind of feel
like a douche yeah i feel like it's a
lot harder selling man stuff you have to
sell hey look how awesome i am look at
the [ __ ] that's kind of what i feel
like
it's really really weird you can do it
that way it's just that
it's so much easier to sell somebody
else's stuff uh
but man yeah well because you're not
emotionally involved yeah right and i
just grabbed people
she see me hey come here i'm like how
you doing
i love your shoes baby which like i said
i can never do that yeah because to me
start talking to him to me that seems
like really obnoxious like if somebody
did that to me i would be like you are
really [ __ ] yeah no but it doesn't
it's a numbers game but it doesn't you
just [ __ ] plow through it
and [ __ ] every person that bought
from you was happy we took pictures
viewing them together and [ __ ] you
know and they reviewed my books later
and i was like yeah yeah all the reviews
were there and the assigned audit signed
copies that was old-school [ __ ] okay
which uh those
those situations really don't [ __ ]
happen too much anymore the same the
[ __ ] conventions are not really
happening well the conventions are
happening but we determined
that it was too expensive
uh to do online sales is more lucrative
yeah yeah i mean the conventions are fun
i do like doing the conventions but
overheads when we did the conventions
before
the the couple conventions we went to
the reason that we did them was because
we were part of you know the you're on
like the horror writer track
so we'll get you in for free
if you do
x y z like if you do these like talk you
entertain these people right so we did
like a bunch of talks like i did one
about twin peaks i did like we did like
all of these i did one about women in
horror like i sat on these panels free
booze right yes so we so we did that so
i said well yeah i'll do all that like
if you pay cause it's expensive like to
get in the [ __ ]
so they paid for our [ __ ] to get in for
three days um if we would sit on
you know a number of panels and so we
did that
and they said okay we'll give you some
table space
and it was us and it was like a bunch of
other horror writers
so bring your own books bring your own
merchandising [ __ ] whatever so we have
all this table space for you so we did
that now the thing about it though is
that
as cool as that was uh and it was pretty
cheap like we had to pay for parking we
had to pay for food we had to pay but we
didn't have to pay to get in so that was
like significant savings
um but the thing about it is that i
don't know i kind of feel like
if you're a horror writer
they kind of like stuck us
they stuck all the horror authors
up on the second floor of the convention
um
a little bit away from
the main action
because i kind of feel like the main
action was
you know all your horror sellers and all
like the you know there's people that
have been horror movies you know like
bruce campbell and all those kind of
people like you know tom savini and all
those kind of people they were there
and then
like you know horror writers horror
novelists and like we're gonna shove you
up in the [ __ ] in the second floor
so i kind of feel like a lot of people
that came to the convention
didn't know that there was like a second
level where there was other [ __ ] going
on up there you know what i'm saying
um
so i kind of feel like there was that
issue as well
so we kind of came to the conclusion
that it's like is it really worth it
because i have to spend a lot of money
like buying books yeah to sell at the
thing like i get them much cheaper
obviously but
you know i still have to spend hundreds
and hundreds of dollars like buying
huge amounts of them
being kind of a wash
you put out a couple hundred bucks then
you might make a hundred and something
buck or a couple hundred bucks back
and maybe you gained 50 bucks
profit yeah i think i maybe ended up
profiting like a hundred something
dollars
because like um i bought
how many books did i buy i bought like
several hundred dollars worth of books
yeah 30 or 40 i think i bought several
hundred dollars worth of books we sell
them all which is good but we also had
to we didn't stay in the hotel we drove
there every day it was three
days gas and all that stuff but with the
gas um
food
parking yeah we'd have to pay to get
into the convention they paid for that
uh which was good because that was a
significant savings but
parking was 15 bucks a day yeah uh gas
not cheap
so we kind of like figured out it's like
well we probably made like zero money
like after i think we know i think we
made more or we made like a little bit i
think we made fifty
but the thing was is that that was a lot
of work
it was [ __ ] like a two or three days
it was a good time i had a good time
we had a good time i'm not saying that
no we partied during all that sure we
did make some money but they were like
wait a minute hold on that was only a
hundred bucks
profit
[ __ ] you know if you you can have a
sometimes
if you have a good online month
you [ __ ]
topped that many times over so why did
we do that you know i mean yeah
i kind of feel like it'd probably be
more worth it it's not weird anymore if
we were bigger yeah
because i do kind of feel like although
we were the biggest ones there
because all the other offers true
authors didn't sell [ __ ] that's true
we sold them we sold the most
and the weird thing about it was that
when i did um
because i did a couple of panels like i
did uh at least one or two panels a day
which like i said they asked me it's
like hey we'll pay for your [ __ ] if
you'll do some panels and i was like
yeah fine so i did like i said a women
in horror one i did twin peaks one
because i'm really into david lynch and
like after
one of the panels i don't remember which
one it was but i had like a couple
people come up and be like oh my god i'm
so into your like 13 o'clock show and
that was like when they wanted their
picture taken they were like big fans
and stuff and i was just like that was
like mind-blowing that was like the show
was almost bigger so some people like
knew who we were which was really cool
but yeah
i don't know i just kind of feel like
i feel like we should be bigger before
that would be worthwhile although we did
have a good time and i'm glad that they
paid for us together you got to keep it
in perspective
we sold we sold more copies than anybody
any author at those things
blown them out of the water and they
were mad i think they were kind of
i think they were because i'd sit there
and just [ __ ] sell and sell and sell
and sell and they wouldn't sell a single
[ __ ] book not a single one because
they don't have any
sales experience you know and and they
didn't have the confidence
writing and selling are two very
different skills yes it's very different
okay i'm not a baby together me and her
can kick ass like i said she gives me
something to sell i'll [ __ ] sell it
especially if i'm in front of you
and i'm and and we were drinking at we
were drinking there
and handing out [ __ ] boo we were
having fun man all right well and when
i'm having fun
i'll [ __ ] i'll start [ __ ]
buttering up whole crowds of people and
just talking [ __ ] to people as they're
going by and sell a book
she saw
yeah yeah i mean he sold pretty much
almost i was trying to sell books to
china i think i had like two [ __ ]
books left yeah and then i had a big
huge box yeah i tried to sell books to
children
children should not be reading my books
yeah i try to sell a bunch of children
and then [ __ ] the parents are like
like they didn't have any money it was
like oh yeah i guess you don't have
anyone
that's right you're a child you never
have ever forgotten you don't have a job
yeah
you remember that right yeah i do yeah
his mom [ __ ] came in well like i said
don't encourage children to be reading
my [ __ ] i don't want to like get sued or
nothing so
yeah though yeah because some people are
excited how did you find this channel
which is that's really interesting to me
because that's
like some information that i feel like i
should probably have uh that's a good
exercise guys how did you find tom and
jenny in my case it was searching for a
logan's run movie review to my surprise
it was a series that i never knew
yeah i kind of feel like a lot of people
man we got so many hits on that logan's
run review because i kind of feel like a
lot of people didn't
well at least when we reviewed it
that was something that a lot of people
didn't have a review on so i kind of
feel like our
man our logan's run review i think
that's still one of our like highest
viewed videos to this day which is crazy
i thought that was like a bigger movie
i saw it a million times when i was a
kid so i kind of thought
i i kind of assumed everyone had seen it
but i guess not
agnes said i don't remember how i found
the channel but i've been listening off
and on for the last two years or so
uh i was listening when it was just
audio no video yeah i remember that
yeah it was like a big deal i think it
was our 200th episode where we were kind
of like hey we're finally going video
hey you can see our faces
i wasn't excited about it but you know
what i mean i was like i don't want
anybody to look at me jesus christ
uh tammy said i was looking for jack the
ripper info found this channel oh see
that's cool
that's cool tom's looking like popeye
now yeah he is
guama khan says i found the channel
because i like reading about shining
theories oh my god don't even get me
started
um i would imagine if you're into
shining theories that you probably
already subscribed to collate of
learning because that dude has a [ __ ]
zillion videos about shining and fairies
and man max and david lynch stuff
i love that guy so
i could talk about the phone shining all
day long all day long
aaron just says ten dollars thank you
very much they're all talking about how
they found the channel because everybody
was asking about that because somebody
was asking about this underground
channel this is an underground channel
thank you aaron yeah you all popped up
when i first discovered stephanie harlow
and did yes i and honestly i really like
stephanie harlow's channel
uh she has a true crime channel in case
you didn't know yeah uh and she talks
about at length about true crime cases
yeah i'm subscribed to her as well
uh hugo said i also found you guys
looking for logan's run i kind of feel
like that was a big thing a lot of
people found us looking for logan's run
reviews very that was a very um
successful
that's right i kind of feel like that's
still one of our highest rated houses i
don't know
i think maybe there's not as many
i don't know and uh maybe they liked
what we said
um
i think i think we reviewed that that
show with a lot of respect
i love that movie though
well and the tv show too it's a very
well thought out movie
it was a well done movie also the only
reason why it really didn't stick was
star wars came out right after it which
just blew it away
but that was a [ __ ] great movie yeah
i love it
maybe they like
my idea that
that the thing was a [ __ ] pod
that once uh
once the main computer found out that
the outside world was safe for life that
it destroyed itself to let all the
people out
i don't think anybody else has ever
thought of that because i've listened to
the other reviews they don't mention
that
but i think that's what they were trying
to say remember how the dome city
collapsed yeah as soon as logan came
back and says you know there is no
sanctuary and all that kind of
i think maybe that can i think maybe it
was supposed to be an arc
to survive all the radiation
just to hold them in stasis
just to have a breeding population
remember they couldn't live past 30.
agnes said was that the one where the
people didn't age they did age
once they got to 30 they would um
they would quote unquote renew yeah
which meant they killed them although
although they didn't
see it that way right they didn't
realize that i thought they were reborn
sure into the into the genetically
engineered union yeah so everyone was
like young yeah and everything was based
around like hedonism yeah it's just to
keep them busy sure
um i thought it was like a like an arc
to um preserve mankind
uh
through a time of [ __ ] nuclear war
when soon as that soon as the message
came back that the outside was safe to
live in
in the movie it shows the main computer
blowing up and the people being released
kind of like opening an
egg
but i don't know
because the book it's based on a book
and the book is very different and then
the tv series
was different that there were a lot of
people that were cheating there were
people in their 40s 50s and 60s also
but they were uh you know in a secret
high council that was that was making
decisions behind the scenes
not everybody died at 30 depending on
who you were
some people were allowed to live longer
well of course right um
but i think the people that were
directing the movie might have tweaked
it a little bit
to make it seem kind of like an arc okay
we're gonna end it we're gonna give it a
happy ending
i think that's for the movie what they
tried to do
because that's kind of what they show
yeah agnes says i just remember the girl
saying wrinkles for the first time or
something like that yeah she saw an old
person she'd never seen an old person
before
hey the movie is good it is it is the
movie's good and i recommend the tv
series the people that wrote the
episodes were the same people that wrote
classic star trek episodes a lot of the
same writers
i mean the movie's good like you should
see the movie first yeah
and then the tv series the tv series is
is worth watching too it has terrible
costumes and special effects for certain
things for cer on certain episodes
but it's okay writing it's pretty good
uh for the team i was entertained yeah
um
it uh heather menzies plays
yeah that's right she's in it
and it's not the same cast of course and
then
they meet up with an android
who is a guy from [ __ ] the movie the
thing
and that android is definitely the uh
prototype for data
oh yeah that's definitely where they got
the idea for data
he's the best character what's his name
lore
no no what that was that was off of star
trek what was that guy's name
from from uh oh [ __ ] no i totally spaced
out um
thank you allen allen just sent us 9.99
oh thank you very much thank you very
much yeah in the uh logan's run
television series there's an android
there that they meet up with i can't
remember his name off the top of my head
but he's he's it'll come to me he's um
he's a real good character and you can
tell that's where they got the idea for
data
and uh
it only lasted i think two seasons was
it two seasons i think it was only two
because it's like a couple cds and uh
it's it's good it's okay
it's not as good as the movie but it's
worth watching it's like old star trek
yeah it's as good as old star trek
yeah ram ram
ram
yeah rim was cool i liked ram yeah he
was a good character yeah he was
actually the best character
he's actually the best character in the
uh yeah
and uh he kind of carried the series
because um yeah one season so it's kind
of up one season okay
because uh jessica played by menzies she
was the hottie of the series she's
basically kind of like a stand-in for
farrah fawcett that's you can kind of
see they're kind of go the fair faucet
like look i have little like metallic
shorts metallic shield all the time
and she's the cutie and she is a good
character she's a good girl in the
character and then but logan is kind of
your boring alpha male young alpha male
guy but he's kind of boring there's not
a lot too hands i have to say he's not
very curious it's generic
really hate on the character but yeah
rem was the last man had all the
character
well yeah
kind of like star trek i was like born
to spock like kirk is cool too like
right yeah and bones is cool too but
come on
spock is like the starting show sorry
thank you jeffy art
jeffy rkc super chat i found your
channel by stumbling on your her
baumeister episode oh yeah during coven
i remember tom's quote if you're going
to be gay be power gay beat
don't be the submissive gay okay be the
power gay i don't know what you're
talking about so we never know
it's been so long ago so we never know i
don't remember the context that's kind
of how i feel about it i'm like look
remember the context our channel
honestly though uh here's one thing i
will say
a lot of horror channels because i
subscribe to a lot of horror channels
horror review channels books movies
whatever because i'm into that
but a lot of them
uh
don't have as many
uh subscribers as we have we have what
12 000
yeah which is not great in youtube
parlance but honestly a lot of the
channels that i really like yeah the
horror ones have a lot less than us like
less than half
so i'm not really all that concerned
about it no uh uh agnes lamps says fair
fossa wasn't in it but heather menzies
is obviously a stand-down i mean she has
the same hair and everything and kind of
the same look
and um
it's because
i was a kid in school when when uh
logan's run came out
and what most guys in the third grade
were saying was ain't fair faucet was it
because everybody had a poster a fair
faucet well i kind of feel like it was
the law
yes you kind of had to have a verified
so they kind of wanted farrah fawcett to
be in the television program but they
couldn't get her they couldn't get it
and she is not a big she does not have a
big role in logan's run she's a side
character
who's only at the plastic surgeries at
plastic surgeon's office
so she was she wasn't jessica jessica
was [ __ ] hotter though if you ask me
she had a much better leg she was that
british actress what's her name
heather menzies
no no no who are you talking the british
actress that played jessica in logan's
run
oh jenny agatha jenny agatha right jenny
agatha was [ __ ] hotter than well and
she was in like lots of music other than
that yeah she was actually hotter than
than farrah fawcett uh yeah i'll agree
with you on that
jenny agatha was super super hot farah
though in in the late 70s had kind of a
new flair she had feathered hair she was
cooler i guess you could say but i know
jenny atticure was but not cool
that's the thing though it's like i kind
of feel like you're cool she's a bimbo
that's what i mean i kind of feel like
look there's bimbo hot yeah and then
there's like actual hot yeah and that's
kind of like the difference between like
look fair hot fair faucet hot
but that's like bimbo hot yeah i'm not
i'm not making a judgment on her as a
person i'm just saying like the look of
her and like the way people perceived
her yeah that was bimbo hot yeah jenny
was just hot jenny agatha was just like
hot all around like she was probably
like super smart and she was just like i
don't know she was like there was
something even in logan's run she was
supposed to come across as like kind of
competent and intellectual
yeah but she had a [ __ ] to me that's
way hotter she had a set of legs on her
and a [ __ ] great waist and a
beautiful face
and she wasn't didn't have real flashy
haircuts or anything she's just
yeah she's just like naturally really
she didn't like
there wasn't like a hole to do collins
said he found us through uh star trek
continues video when he saw star trek
continue series when it ended he cried
dude so did i the innocent i did too
kind of you're choking up yeah you're
chilling out i did too dear when
yeah if you guys have not seen star trek
continues
it's free on youtube
uh in hd watch it
it is the final episode of
of the original star trek it's the final
season of the original star trek
series with kirk and spock
they
flesh it out
so it me so it mates up with um
star trek the motion picture of what
happened to spock and what happened to
the [ __ ]
it's very good very and a lot of people
that worked on that
also were writers and people that worked
on the original star trek the guy who
played scotty in it was the son of the
guy who plays scotty yeah it had a
[ __ ] it's just got a very good cast
of course it's not the original cast but
they did but it was everybody that was
like they were really really into the
original they're really and it is it is
and they wanted to recreate it as
faithfully as possible it's the same
aspect ratio it's the same [ __ ] music
same score i love it the way it should
love and it's shot in hd and it's the
same writing and it all fits right they
wanted it to look exactly the same
it is pure classic star trek
and they even go back and do a mirror
episode
to find out what happened in mirror
mirror
what happened to mirror spock that one
what him
what happened to him how sexy is yeah
what did he do did he actually have the
the revolt and yeah he did he launched a
rebellion i think it's i think it's
episode three but just go back and watch
the whole series of star trek continues
and you and they'll they'll [ __ ] it
picks up where the original series left
off and goes right
to
goes right to [ __ ] star trek the
motion picture
it even ends with the [ __ ] theme of
star trek the motion picture
i mean they put a really lot of
[Music]
that and like i said i appreciate that
yeah anytime anybody's like so nerdy
about that that it's like we want
everything to like [ __ ]
fit into this gap
yep [ __ ] i see you i respect that yeah
i did and the guy playing the guy
playing kirk is
he is a trekkie extraordinaire and he's
not doing a shatner impersonation
uh he's just doing kirk he's channeling
kirk he has a slightly different way of
doing it but it's close man it's real
close he said he said he could
impersonate
he could impersonate william shatner
well it's easy to impersonate he didn't
want to do that he wanted to just do it
his own way yeah what's his name
well that's the thing it's like
it's very easy to like
impersonate yeah that like but
i kind of feel like he does a really
good job of like
doing that character
but not like making fun of that right
vic was uh did a lot of acting and uh
did a lot of voice acting for anime
did a lot of the uh and he said when he
was a little boy he wanted to be captain
kirk and [ __ ] that this was his he
helped put that whole project together
because he wanted to play the role of
captain kirk and he [ __ ] knocks it
out of the park and and uh havercorn
todd haberkorn does i think his name is
todd habercorn uh does does uh
spock
he's a little he's a lot younger than
leonard nimoy was but he's still good
still good still real good i still like
his take still real good [ __ ] todd
haberkorn spock i accept that as [ __ ]
this is okay that's spock
that's back yeah and uh you had a dude
from playing [ __ ] sulu the guy from
[ __ ] um
uh
[ __ ] mythbusters mythbusters what's
his name the dude that passed away yeah
he died
um sadly he yeah the japanese guy from
um mythbusters from mythbusters what was
his name
sorry i'm drunk i'm like phasing out
although i might need another drink okay
i'll get you a helmet
but no i oh we did a show on it
and i [ __ ] really recommend if you
guys have not seen star trek i mean it
is very if you like the original star
trek which i do yeah tom does yeah i
love original star trek more than any
other star trek
um
yeah star trek continues is really
really good i mean i just love the i
love the love they put into it i love
the
attention to detail they put into it i
love that kind of stuff if you're that
geeky
about something it's just like look i
have the money and i'm just gonna like
i'm gonna
replicate this
as much i
i love that i love that and the fact
that they did that and they went all
they went all in and i'm really really
on board
uh agnes says jenny do you like it when
tom talks about girls that way
uh
uh
i don't know it's just kind of like
that's just kind of what he does
um i don't feel one way or the other
about it
honestly um
i kind of like
uh that's like an awkward question
agnes is asking if i
like it when tom talks about girls that
way what what the [ __ ] why are you but i
said why is she asking that here's the
thing um
i don't know it's like
one that's just what you're like
we're doing a show too yeah um
i can appreciate hot girls also right uh
so
i kinda like hot girls too
they don't they don't know everything so
i kind of like hot girls too
jenny if i have messed up jenny and i
mess around
with
with with girls with the girls
everything i don't know what you're
talking
about i like hot girls i like hot girls
let me go to the restaurant honestly if
you're gonna like talk to me about like
hot people i i'm more into hot girls
than hot toots honestly
i said you know i like some hot dudes
too but
hot girls are
hotter than hot dudes i'm just gonna say
that right now so if you're gonna talk
about like jenny agatha if you're gonna
talk about like [ __ ]
i don't know
the thing about it is that if you ask me
right now
jenny think of some like hot actor that
you're into
i could probably think of a few but
honestly i could think of a lot hotter
like uh
hotter female
actresses than i could like hot male
actors
i'm just going to say ginny didn't like
guys
i do but
it's limited it's limited yeah yeah you
gotta make sure you've got a [ __ ]
strength stringent taste
well
it's not so much that i'm i'm pretty
like
i don't know i don't know if i have like
a taste so much as this kind of like i'm
kind of like
i kind of come at it more as like an
individualistic thing but if you're just
going to talk about physically hot
most of the time physically hot i'm
going to talk about like women and
physically hotter than
like some dudes are physically hot okay
but it's like i'm
i'm more into like women physically hat
sorry
that's just kind of how it goes so
kahn's talking about saturn 5 and [ __ ]
yeah that was another good movie
that was a good movie yeah i liked
kirk douglas's naked ass walking around
kirk douglas they said he got too
comfortable being naked and [ __ ] he's
starting everyone is very uncomfortable
he was getting comfortable yes dude
you're like 80. knock it off we don't
want to see your saggy butt
he did but still
um saturn five was a good movie that uh
saturn three it's actually called sign
of three isn't it no i think it's center
five isn't it it's a center five percent
i'm pretty sure seven three okay
that was a good movie uh
am i drunk or i'm pretty sure it's out
on three i think i think
kong's called it five
i think i'd have been stating three i
thought it was out of three
it was kind of like alien it was kind of
like something from the ridley scott
universe
good movie it had harvey keitel
farah fawcett
kirk douglas
very expensive set
um
they were doing good on it it had a lot
of good story elements
but they started to run out of money
towards the end
and it didn't end
without big enough yeah it's three i'm
trying to three three yeah thank you
it didn't end with it made me question
myself
but you can watch saturn three and see
what could have been when you see it in
hd it's a lot better than it was on
television when i was kid
i only saw it on television that's still
a good movie though and it really
[ __ ] was ahead of its time
dude had first name hara that was what
was that great brandon
right that's right great
grand grand yamahara plays sulu and um i
can't believe he died yeah he died jesus
christ
um but uh saturn three was really good i
mean [ __ ] harvey keitel had a neural
link
to a [ __ ] cybernetic
robot
the robot had three or four human brains
in it they were grown in a vat
through dna
and it was what was called the [ __ ]
ulysses or the [ __ ] uh i don't
remember what kind of [ __ ] anyway was
this badass robot and he murdered a dude
to get that job
and failed a bunch of [ __ ] to get out
there to [ __ ] saturday he was a
criminal
and tried to program that robot with
that new neural length and when it
neural link when when it was done
collating with him it was attracted to
[ __ ] pharaoh faucet
and [ __ ] was wanted to have set was
in love with her and he was beating that
robot up what are you going to do with
her what are you going to do with her
you can't do anything
that thing [ __ ] cut his hand on and
[ __ ] tore his face off and was
wearing it and tried to become him
ah that was [ __ ] some weird [ __ ] it
was it was a good story
real and they they called a lot of [ __ ]
neural links
that was ahead of me well i mean maybe
people weren't wireless [ __ ] back in the
day well and also the whole thing about
farrah fawcett and
naked as kirk douglas running around
maybe that was a little bit too much for
people to take i don't think so i mean i
liked it at the time i did too but
he's like old as [ __ ]
well that was part of the story i know
but part of the story was is that he was
obsolete remember yeah and then he was
going to kind of be put down
eventually
and uh they were out there on that
[ __ ] on saturn three growing food
and she was like venus to him and they
were kind of like
they were kind of like in the garden of
eden and then satan shows up which is
this dude
it was just a good [ __ ] story i
thought it's just that they didn't
there wasn't enough action at the end
it was trying to be an alien rip-off
yeah i kind of feel like that was a
reaction at the end i mean it was good
up to then right um
harvey keitel who was very very young in
this movie actually like was a good
antagonist right but i did kind of feel
like i kind of feel like that was the
only downfall of the movie it was a
little anticlimactic yeah that's the
only thing and they said that they had
it had a lot of problems in production
and they ran out of money
and and and then the space shots were
shitty they [ __ ] hired a japanese
company
to do it so you like touhou so it ended
up looking like a godzilla movie
some of the [ __ ] shots that happened
in space
were kind of crazy but i forgive the
movie for what it was i still like it i
still like it but it was gonna be
something is up there with like alien
they were trying to compete with alien
honestly when i watch a movie i'm just
kind of like
look what were you trying to tell me
like i don't like look i understand if
you didn't have enough money i relate
um you know but what were you trying to
tell me what what is the thing you were
trying to like achieve or put across
um
you know so i'm willing to like give a
lot of leeway i've seen like a lot of
shitty movies in my life so you know
uh
jenny agatha was hot i agree
i agree american werewolf in london yeah
she was in that too and uh she was
fantastic man i love jenny agatha i
really do
uh omri vampire says i think the i i
first watched your haunting episodes
thomas jenny laughed so much with the
sarcasm in the summer when a team of
child reviews man said i couldn't where
is that raccoon honestly
oh my god the demon child show
i think we made a whole made a shirt
about that show
because that show
that was one of the ones that like even
when i saw it back in the like before i
even met him it was just kind of like oh
my god that's [ __ ] hilarious a
[ __ ] child because like i hate
children so i thought that was like
super super funny
like that he was
being a team and i was like he's peeing
in the closet and they thought he was
possessed like and
how is that different like look i have
two brothers so
i i wouldn't have thought they were
possessed i just thought they were being
boys but okay so there was an old thing
so but the fact that he sat on the cat
that like upset me
uh but yeah so we should probably do
some more haunting episodes that's what
i'm saying
uh if you see saturn
3 beware of kirk douglas naked ass it
looks like he did not give it up a [ __ ]
he absolutely did not absolutely not
which like i said
hey
he's an old dude he wants to run around
naked
uh
hey you do you
a little weird um because farrah fawcett
was
obviously
several decades younger but
okay
i'll watch it look just show me what you
got okay so what was that
adriana c says helen mirren total hottie
all around too oh i agree with that
helen marin
uh
you know who helen merritt is she was
the one that played for in excalibur oh
yeah yeah there's the sorceress chick
well like i said she was in some [ __ ]
later on too she was in like all those
like uh british true crime shows that i
was like super into yeah yeah that was i
love helen mirren she would have been
like something from like an old school
late 70s early 80s pet house magazine
that she was like a penthouse pet for
that time hottie howdy she had a great
nose too long [ __ ] pointed nose yeah
she was cute
bad girl
she just came across as a bad girl i
mean yeah yeah
honestly another in a good way another
uh chick that i was into that time yeah
isabella who pair
the french actress
man i don't know that one ooh
that [ __ ] so sexy yeah um she's like in
i don't know what it is about her i
can't like put my finger on i've seen
like pretty much every movie she's been
in
um
but there's just really something about
her that is like i don't know what it is
but she's like there's something like
really really like sexy about it earlier
how they thought it was funny talking
about like man that you know man said i
could and all that and the [ __ ]
looking for the raccoon that's the old
stuff that was the old stuff yeah we
should probably do another haunting
episode yeah we'll do another haunted
house i will have to look into
i got them all we'll go look we'll have
to look into like ones we haven't done
before yeah i have to look back on our
because we've done like almost 300
episodes at this point this episode i
think we only did four or five haunting
episodes though
yeah like the last episode we did was
297 so we're almost to 300 episodes okay
and
we did several
episodes about the haunt i know we did
like bobby what does that do bobby
mackies or whatever we did that
we did summer wins we did haunting in
florida like the one that was in deland
we did that yeah i know um
yeah because you know that yeah we did
that
um we did the one about mr gordy yeah
the georgia one haunting in georgia
um what else did we do
i know we did more than that did we do
the one where um
they had the well out in the back i
think art bell even had that on this
show yes we did that okay well that was
the one that was um
that was the one
[ __ ] was that dude's name
uh that was the one that actually like
went to a court case because it was like
[ __ ] kind
yeah what are those [ __ ]
i don't know [ __ ] i just spaced out okay
the demonologists demonologists
you know who i'm talking about oh the
couple yeah yeah yeah what are their
names what are their names what are the
names what are their names the lorraine
there you go and lorraine
yeah they they were involved with that
with the whole well with the damon yeah
we did a show about that
um because we did a couple shows about
the warrens i think right uh so we can
cover all kinds of hate
well they like them and they hate them
at the same time i guess
those are our most watched shows yeah
but those are the ones that get the most
amount of like people being like you
guys you guys understand the power of
christ and this and that well yeah
we don't get so much of that nowadays
but those [ __ ] have never even seen
anything paranormal i have so [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm not worried about it
it's it's not
not there's not a single religion that
has a [ __ ] monopoly on paranormal it
exists in every religion they have their
own
take on it islam
calls it the islam has ghosts but they
also have [ __ ]
uh a gin
which is kind of like a poltergeist
guy yes it's essentially the same thing
if you were to show a fault if you were
to bring a person of islamic background
and and let them see a poltergeist
incident they would say it was jib
jin or demon
same thing
yeah like i said it's kind of some kind
of
we thought it was kind of demon ghosty
kind of thing too it's ghosty yeah but
it takes time to get through that phase
it's it's uh
rspk
agnes says have you ever heard of popper
the poltergeist yes i have uh i wrote
about that in my book
that was the
poltergeist that was like popping all
the caps
off the bottles like bleach bottles and
stuff like that okay i don't remember
that one i don't think we either there's
a lot of them i don't see well this is
like a big uh
it was a fairly famous case and it was
one of the ones that i think that the
poltergeist thing the movie was based on
and uh i wrote about it my book but i
don't think we did a show about it i did
write about it though
but yeah that was actually like a really
good case
and it's from the 50s yeah that's right
uh and as i said i've had paranormal
experiences yeah we have as well tom
more than me but
you know she's seen it i've seen it as
well you've seen it more than me but
yeah
when you see it she's analytical so
she's she knew what it was because i had
already kind of promised yeah it didn't
scare me because i was just kind of like
oh you're doing this [ __ ] yeah
it's a weird thing
it's creepy but it well it's weird
because it's like it was creepy but it
didn't scare me
it didn't scare me
you said that time you walked through
that damn bathroom though you felt you
kind
there was like a weird kind of like
feeling and i was just kind of like ooh
it was just kind of like like that but
it's just kind of like
i kind of i felt like that only because
oh it's like some un you know
untread territory i guess it was but i
knew it was probably you
so i wasn't
i didn't have the same fear of it as
it would be if i
if i thought that it was like a demon
because i don't believe like in demons
or anything like that i don't really
feel like it's
necessarily harmful
because i knew that it was probably you
it didn't scare me because i knew that
like you better not [ __ ] throw some
bricks at me poltergeistery because
you'll be in big trouble yeah so i kind
of feel like it didn't
because it stemmed from you it didn't
really scare me
is what i was saying
yeah i said you know it came from tom so
it wasn't scary yeah that's that's kind
of how i thought about it
you know yeah
i mean it could be well
well some [ __ ] that happened because
there was some [ __ ] and
you know we've talked about this before
but there was some [ __ ] that i wasn't
home i was at work
but some [ __ ] that happened
you were in the house you got upset
about something yeah and a bunch of uh
statues that were up over the
uh cabinets in the kitchen yeah and a
[ __ ] bunch of wood yeah and a bunch
of wood like it all like flew off and
all the statues came off and broke yeah
it was pulled off too and the little
pulled off yeah the wood was pulled off
like all the nails were [ __ ] up it was
weird man it had not it happened when my
back was turned and it happened
instantly boom
like a gunshot and that happened because
you were mad
he wasn't mad at me i wasn't home
um but he told me about it later yeah
so
the woman from the housing commission
was there she saw it but she was like
what was that
she turned around
i don't know
yeah that was some weird that was some
weird [ __ ] but
yeah
so the fact that i knew that your anger
was capable of doing something like that
it did bother me
but
i don't know i just
i wasn't really all that concerned i'm
like man if he's ever gonna like direct
that [ __ ] at me then
not a lot i could do about it i've never
it's never been and i don't like it
and i don't think and yeah and i don't
think you've ever been that mad at me
it's always indirect it's always an
objects just never add a person yeah
it may not be possible to do it to
prison i don't know
yeah you might have some kind of thing
where it's like because i kind of feel
like like [ __ ] like that has happened
that was like destructive
but it wasn't directed at a person yeah
um maybe it's like a fail-safe mess
that's what i mean like you were mad but
it just kind of like it could be that
you can't conflict too much with another
consciousness
they would prevent it
it has to be in a zone where it's
against it yeah maybe that's me being
like back up yeah well no it might be
that you can only do that to something
that is not inanimate because it doesn't
have a conscious
i don't
know
i told you after that happened i was
like [ __ ] look look if you get mad at
me and like subconsciously like throw a
brick at me i'm gonna like really get
really upset
so don't be doing that it doesn't it
doesn't seem to work that way
well happily yeah happily yeah
because i it did occur to me it did
occur to me
but watching we were sitting there
[ __ ] watching television
and um
two friends of ours were sitting on the
couch and that tv remote [ __ ] flew
off the [ __ ] couch and flew off the
[ __ ] uh table the table and hit the
[ __ ] ground and went boom
and it hit hard sound and it didn't make
that same sound when you drive and both
of them
looked at me and their eyes were big
like this yeah and i didn't even see it
i was kind of zoned out i was like yeah
i was sounding out
it was weird well they kind of knew
because i told them they knew like they
knew about it right
but they'd never seen it
but they were there if they didn't come
over to see it they just came over to
watch a movie and like hang out and have
dinner or whatever so we're like sitting
around the living room trying to watch a
movie
and
we're sitting around we're trying to
watch the movie it was mad max fury road
i remember i got frustrated we were
trying to rent it and it was like there
was all kind of technical difficulties
tom's getting frustrated yeah and
at some point before it came on
all of a sudden we're just sitting
around like waiting for some technical
uh things to be sorted out and all of a
sudden the remote control
on the
table
on the coffee table
picked up
and went
bam
on the floor
did you see it was is was was it one
stroke or two motions
i'm not sure because i saw
okay i was looking over it like it okay
i was on this
table i was on the couch right here yeah
table was right in front of me but i
wasn't looking i was looking at the tv
which was like my sight line was a
little bit above that you're right but i
did see like motion
and i was like what the [ __ ]
and then all of a sudden i see the
remote control
i didn't see it pick up off the table
but i saw it
moving right
and then it hit the floor and it hit the
floor in a weird way it hit the floor
like
wham like it was like and it stuck yeah
i remember that part
i remember the sound
yeah and it made us sound like it was
way heavier like a brick boom which to
me i was just kind of like yeah
and like for a second like my foot was
on the
coffee table
and for a second i thought did my foot
kick that it's like what and then like i
looked over
at our friends yeah because we had uh
you know demetria and jammer here yeah
and i looked at them like did you just
see that jan's eyes were the size of it
and their eyes were like like did you
see that i was like did you [ __ ] see
that did you just [ __ ] see that
and they're like we [ __ ] saw that
yeah and i was like okay i thought that
was like imagine i thought i kicked the
table or something yeah they're like nah
and i was kind of i kind of shook my
head like what you were like spaced out
you didn't know what's going on and then
went oh it moved and i stood up and went
really and i felt it coming over me and
i looked down at my feet there was a
stack of coins
yeah that was a weird night yes and my
feet were a stack of coins and the coins
came from the [ __ ] bedroom
yeah that was a weird name it was a
stack of quarters and pennies wasn't it
yeah
yeah i was like what's this doing here
yeah because you moved your foot and it
was like
[Music]
okay i know what's happening and i
[ __ ] because that's the way it was
the [ __ ] mouth mountain so i know
what's happening
and then
and then dmitri was like tom do it again
do it again yeah dimitri was like yeah
tom do it again do it again do it again
he says yeah and it was starting to kind
of [ __ ] come come down yeah it was
like you could feel it like no no you
could feel it yeah it was like a whole
weird like everyone's hair was standing
up yeah yeah yeah it was like a whole
thing yeah he was telling me to do it
again again do it again and i was like
oh no
i could i could feel like evil and
[ __ ] and i could feel
fear and evil welling up and now i
didn't want to go down that path well
then honestly like i was just kind of
like
yeah probably but
i mean i told you like because it was
the living room and i was like well i
have to go pee or whatever and like i
went into the bedroom
because we had the bathroom uh in the
bedroom and i was like well i have to go
to the bathroom and at that point i was
just kind of like oh it's like super
creepy yeah then i kind of felt like it
was like super creepy but before
prior to that
because i feel like it's you
yeah
it's not an unknown force
so
to me it wasn't like scary it was like
it was kind of exciting it was kind of
scary but like not i didn't think
anything
bad was gonna happen to me i don't think
i was gonna die or anything so it was
just kind of like
i kind of like i kind of got like
demetrius thing like do it again like i
kind of got you wanted to see it happen
again yeah yeah
well he had heard about it you're right
and he was seeing it so he was just kind
of like holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] you weren't like making it up
yeah
and so the fact that he saw that happen
like in front of his face yeah and i saw
it happen in front of my face that
[ __ ] [ __ ] flew
it did
um and like i said i'm a skeptic i would
not like [ __ ] say that if it didn't
happen it absolutely did
that [ __ ]
picked up off the
coffee table
and flew off like that picked up when it
picked up did it
did it come up and stop and then go over
or i'm not entirely sure because i only
saw it because like i said i was looking
over it
so i only saw it like in the bottom of
my vision yeah i kind of feel like
i kind of feel like i only saw it when
it was like
already in motion that's the way it was
so i didn't really see it pick up off
the table but it was already
yeah it's flying at mammoth or even at
the other house whenever i saw something
moving it was already moving when you
see it yeah and that's already been yeah
and
it always looked slightly blurry
for something yeah did it look blurry
did it look kind of blurry it did a
little bit like that like there's trails
behind it a little bit yeah you're not
really focusing straight at it because
before that time i was playing me i was
playing that damn mad max video game
about probably a week before that and i
was [ __ ] getting [ __ ] all in and
getting frustrated
and the [ __ ] curtain on the damn
sliding door [ __ ] moved and it was
like a wind
and it went to the
like
but there was no wind in the [ __ ]
house yeah but it's like a wind blew the
curtain and it went to the bookshelf
and i saw something go and it hit the
ground
and it was that plastic measuring cup
yeah fell from like one shelf through
all the other shells and hit the bottom
and vibrated on its base
and i [ __ ] hit pause and looked at it
and it was just sitting there
and i went over there and looked and it
was deep into the [ __ ]
shelf you know what i mean but it had to
come out
and and then go in
but it was
it fell three shells down yeah at least
three or four
it went through them
but it just looked like a [ __ ] streak
it went straight down
it's weird man
it's because it's uh for something about
matter is not as solid as you think it
is
you know what i mean it's mostly empty
space so this has something to do with
quantum physics well the thing about it
too is that i kind of feel like people
want to attribute some meaning to it
it's just something but there's really
not it's just kind of like it's random
the random spasms i mean the [ __ ] that
you did yeah like i said the whole thing
with the cup you were just playing a
video game yeah and you got mad yeah and
so this cup
apparently i wasn't mad at that time
though or you know
and it just and a cup or whatever it was
just like went down apparently like two
or three shelves yeah
without well it also moved the curtains
and move the curvature move the curtains
and went down so it was some kind of
wave of but it didn't mean anything no
that's what i'm saying it didn't mean
anything and the whole thing about you
getting angry
and all of those
horse statues it's not so much anger
it's coming out yeah and coming out and
breaking and like all that stuff that
you didn't like it didn't mean anything
no it was you were just mad or
frustrated it was frustration right it's
not anger it's frustration
of not being able to do anything else
yeah and that it just like
busted out in that particular fashion
so
that's but like i said you got to watch
because
that that could be dangerous you don't
know how that's going to manifest
i am worried about it well you don't
have to i got all kinds of dangerous
[ __ ] around here i'm physically a lot
more dangerous than that
um you know what i mean that does not
make me feel i'm far more dangerous than
that just with physicality i'm not
worried about these little [ __ ]
parlor tricks
[ __ ] uh it's but there it is an
indication of that physics isn't what we
think it is
that mind
can manipulate what you would call
matter but matter doesn't mean much it's
there's not much to that matter it's
mostly empty space
and it has something to do with quantum
physics and
what i'm talking about
go look at stuart hameroff's stuff and
[ __ ]
stuart hamroffen uh [ __ ] what's his
name uh what's that other guy the guy
with the [ __ ] physicist that stuart
deals with um
roger penn roger penrose sir roger sir
roger penrose they know all about the
[ __ ]
they know something's up with the
[ __ ] with the model
of physics
it's not what you think it is mind has
something to do with it your ability to
perceive things has something to do with
reality
um
how you look at something
[ __ ] alters
[ __ ]
how real something is that's the best
way i could
describe it
because i didn't really have i guess
because growing up with wesley i didn't
really have a good
limits when it came to what was possible
and what wasn't possible anything was
possible
from my point of view is all possible
and so it makes it happen
and faith is part of it i've always
there's always been an element of faith
of [ __ ] going yeah and allowing
certain things to happen
because you don't care or just like yeah
that's how it is
and
to fire it up you can't do it [ __ ]
from zero
you remember when all that [ __ ] happened
because i was thinking about it for
several months
because it had to do with writing the
book
so
it's like
kind of like those
taoist priests they say well to do this
and that it's going to take me a couple
weeks of preparation
you know what i mean and then i'll do it
i'll be able to do it gotta get in the
right mindset for it so i'm gonna say
that kind of checks out
a lot of the stuff that i'm talking
about is something that would take you a
few weeks to get the ball
rolling to get the proper mindset to
allow it to happen
well and the thing about it too and i
kind of feel like this is true of a lot
of things
is that
people think um
[Music]
to do certain things you need to like
think about it but
that kind of situation you need to like
not think about it which is harder than
you might imagine it's more like
stopping your mind and a lot of feelings
which like i said very very difficult
very difficult especially for somebody
like me because i can't stop my like my
brain from you you have to stop but
stop the intricate process of thought
yep and you have to allow certain things
and it has a lot of allowing feelings to
take over things
and allowing images and feelings to take
over
and
it's not you
it's always
like it's something higher above you
that's doing it
you know what i mean
like the power of god or the force or
something
it's attributed to something outside of
yourself
so
that kind of goes back to the idea of
[ __ ] the unconscious
what's his name what was that guy who
did all the [ __ ]
um
wrote that book about the power of the
unconscious mind uh
wait freud are young young young the
young it's youngy and stuff about the
[ __ ] uh the
the unconscious that's that's what uh
that's what i'm talking about it's that
i just really can't
it's it's stuff that involves other
dimensions i guess you could say another
it's so it's not something especially
when i'm drunk i can't really [ __ ] uh
put it to words it's it's just a feeling
you know
agnes asks do you ever feel someone
touch you no um the only time i've ever
had that happen
was
when i was a little bit younger i was in
my grandmother's house
and
my grandfather had died his ashes were
in a urn like in the
you know in the uh cabinet like behind
me
and i was sitting in the dining room
table
and
the cabinet was behind me
and for whatever reason i felt very very
strongly
that someone
was standing behind me touching my
shoulder
i had never felt that before or since
but it was very very strong and like you
know i'm like super skeptical i don't
like buy any of that kind of crap
but this was like the first time i'd
ever kind of felt like that i was like
what the [ __ ] so much so that i like
turned around
i thought there was somebody
back there whenever rspk or poultry guy
stuff ever happened to me it was always
felt like you're being watched
nothing not that you're being touched
like something's watching you well this
was the same kind of thing i just felt
like someone was
standing right behind me you're right
behind watching you right yeah i felt
like somebody's staying right behind me
and because like i you know my
grandfather's ashes were right behind me
in the cabinet in the urn right
so i kind of feel like maybe that's what
it was because he had only died like a
year or two previous so i kind of like
was weirded out by that so i was like
why my grandfather would be like hanging
around
he didn't seem like the type of dude
that would hang around you know how long
we've been doing the show uh three hours
and 17 minutes okay it's almost time i
know but we're having a good time
we're having a good time
uh i'm marie van pere says
i live in a house where the man who
built it died in the guest room
yet he only manifests when i'm upset
about something
i wonder if i'm triggering it so i try
not to let myself get too angry or sad
i kind of feel like i said i don't
believe in ghosts really or anything
like that but
i have had a couple experiences look i
grew up in a house
a house that i spent a lot of time in as
a
youngster
was the same house that uh many of my
my mom and a lot of her siblings had
grown up it was my grandparents house
and
they all thought that house was haunted
they said we hear people walking around
on the roof we've had like our blankets
pulled off in the middle of the night
and
i was kind of like into that honestly i
was i thought it was really cool but
like when i was younger i was kind of
like hoping that i would like come
across like some hot [ __ ]
you know what i mean and it never really
happened
but
i don't know i i do kind of feel like
maybe i'm not like discounting their
experiences or nothing like that but
nothing
weird ever happened to me in that house
although that house did
have enough of an impact on me that i
still like write stories about it to
this day because it you know i i did
spend a lot of time there as a kid and
it was like a creepy house
uh you know it was like a creepy
two-story house been torn down it's not
there anymore
but
so the fact that that happened uh is
good but
i don't know i didn't have anything
happen there but i
wished it would i wished it would but it
never did
but
i don't know i don't know
it just kind of seems to me that
what happened nothing oh okay
i don't know i kind of feel like i don't
know if i believe
i don't know if i believe in ghosts in
the sense that this is a person
this is a person that you know
that is still haunting you from the
afterlife that's still like the same
person that you recognize
i don't know if i believe that i just
really don't
it's possible
i mean
i haven't experienced that myself
so
i don't know
i don't know how much of that is
possible
yeah
um i'm skeptical about that i'm
skeptical about how much people's
personalities survive after death
i'm very skeptical about that adriana
says you believe in aliens of course oh
yeah there's definitely aliens i mean
yeah it depends on what you're talking
about right uh are you talking about
like aliens that
have come here or
do they exist oh i absolutely believe
that they exist yeah have they come here
that's another question there's been
some [ __ ] great signings
um there have but
i don't really know like most of those
probably our kind of like just [ __ ] we
invented this crazy and like people
weren't like maybe people came by like
aliens came by or just checking and they
were just kind of like hey what's going
on in there okay bye yeah whether or not
they're biological we don't know
probably yeah it's just why not so i
don't know i do i believe that people
are being like picked up and like probed
and stuff absolutely no no no
they're [ __ ] yeah flying saucers
landing and having sex with some dude
those dudes those people have other
issues yeah no those people have their
issues i don't i don't believe that's
true absolutely not all right jenny
it's getting late we gotta go ahead and
shut the show down and i'll make us some
need
you ready to get something to eat what
you gonna make i don't know
you don't know see i'll see
your stuff down there
might make some noodles or something
it'll sound good yeah good jenny always
likes noodles
agnes says i believe in aliens i once
saw a ufo yeah it's like honestly
i don't doubt that aliens are out there
i don't
do they come here and like give people
anal probes and stuff i don't believe
that i believe that because why would
they i i kind of feel like
any uh aliens that were sufficiently
advanced
would
not need to come here and stick stuff up
our butts
so anybody that has that kind of story
i kind of feel like they probably that's
their own thing so you know
uh
yeah those ones have sex they only have
problems yeah absolutely i agree
all right so
tom has taken off
he's left his glasses here
i assume that he's going to make some
food hopefully
but yeah
so i guess
that it's the end of the show
yeah we'll see him
we'll see him win oh okay
sunday sunday we'll see you guys we're
going to talk about a movie yeah we
don't know a movie yet maybe
maybe we should well we could talk about
dogs of war or we could go see a north
man tomorrow okay
maybe if it's still playing we'll see
how it feel
maybe we'll see
or maybe we could do that later okay
here we go
uh but yeah so
hopefully you guys had a good time
thank you for all the super chats thank
you for hanging out with us on this
friday evening
we will see you guys on sunday when we
talk about a movie
we will see you guys sunday good night